I'm Jenna Fischer. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello. Hi. Can I share that we both missed our turns on the way to work today and then we were both late? Yeah. It was so crazy. I was talking to my mom and I missed my exit. We were just like jabbering away. And then I was like, oh, no, mom, I got to go. I've gone the wrong way. Well, I saw a text from you pop up on my little screen and I played
我是詹娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极版《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有亲历者才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。大家好。嗨。我能说我们俩今天上班路上都错过了路口，然后都迟到了吗？对。太疯狂了。我跟我妈说话，结果错过了出口。我们俩就在那儿叽里呱啦地聊。然后我就想，哦，天哪，妈，我得挂了。我走错路了。好吧，我看到你的短信弹在我的小屏幕上，然后我播放了
it, you know, wireless and everything. Just saying. Yes, yes, folks. It was a message where it was like, you know, in the robot voice. Yeah, because I use Siri. Yes. Telling me that you missed your turn off the freeway. I called it my stupid exit. I missed the stupid exit. Well, while I was listening to that, I guess I missed my turn because all of a sudden I was like this giant, I don't know. Like a shopping mall. Yes. It had a Staples and McDonald's and I thought, I've never seen this before. Where am I? I had gone almost a mile out of my way. I had to turn around. So I don't know what that says about today's podcast, but we both missed our turn. Let's get to the episode today. It is Dwight K.
它，你知道的，无线连接什么的。只是顺便说一下。对，对，各位。那是一个消息，你知道的，用机器人的声音说。对，因为我用Siri。对。告诉我你错过了下高速公路的出口。我管它叫我的愚蠢出口。我错过了那个愚蠢的出口。好吧，当我听那个的时候，我想我大概也错过了路口，因为突然之间我看到一个巨大的，我不知道。就像一个购物中心。是的。那里有一家斯台普斯和一家麦当劳，我想，我从来没见过这个。我在哪儿？我偏离路线快有一英里了。我不得不调头。所以我不知道这说明了今天播客的什么情况，但我们俩都错过了路口。我们来聊聊今天的剧集吧。那是德怀特·K·
Schrute, Acting Manager. Acting in parentheses. It is season seven, episode 24, written by Justin Spitzer and directed by Troy Miller. I get very excited for episodes written by Justin. I think he is so funny. He's so funny. He has now gone on to create two amazing television shows Superstore and American Auto. Here's your summary. Acting Manager Dwight is drunk on power and his coworkers are not happy with the changes he has implemented in the office. But an incident with a firearm might save them from his reign of terror. Reign of terror is some strong language. Meanwhile, Gabe is struggling with his breakup with Aaron. Gabe kind of broke my heart. Very much. Fast fact number one, this was our first episode without
施鲁特，代理经理。代理加了括号。这是第七季第二十四集，由贾斯汀·斯皮策编剧，特洛伊·米勒执导。我对贾斯汀编剧的剧集总是非常兴奋。我觉得他太有趣了。他太有趣了。他后来又创作了两部精彩的电视剧《超级超市》和《美式汽车》。剧情简介如下：代理经理德怀特被权力冲昏了头脑，他的同事们对他在办公室推行的新变革很不满意。但一次枪支走火事件可能会让他们免于他的恐怖统治。恐怖统治这个词用得有点严重。与此同时，盖布正在挣扎于他和亚伦的分手。盖布有点伤了我的心。非常伤。趣味冷知识一，这是我们没有
Steve or Will. And according to Wikipedia, the fewest people tuned into this with the exception of Todd Packer. Todd Packer was our lowest watched episode. Am I saying that right? This was our second lowest. Our lowest viewed episode was Todd Packer. Well, Miles McNutt would agree with that. But I disagree with this episode. I think this is a fantastic episode. Listen, people didn't watch it, but critics loved it. Oh. Including Miles McNutt. Yay. He gave it a B. He called it, quote, a nice step forward for the show. Alan Sepinwall from Hit Flicks said, quote, I said I didn't really want to start to judge the post-Corell version of the show until D'Angelo was gone. Well, he's gone. And the first real impression
史蒂夫或威尔的第一集。根据维基百科的说法，除了托德·帕克那一集，这一集的收看人数是最少的。托德·帕克是我们收视率最低的一集。我没说错吧？这是我们收视率倒数第二的一集。我们收视率最低的一集是托德·帕克。好吧，迈尔斯·麦克纳特会同意这一点的。但我不同意这一集。我觉得这是一集棒极了的剧集。听着，虽然大家没看，但评论家们很喜欢。哦。包括迈尔斯·麦克纳特在内。耶。他给它打了个B。他称之为，引述一下，“该剧向前迈出的很好的一步”。来自Hit Flicks的艾伦·塞平沃尔说，引述一下，“我说过，在德安吉洛离开之前，我真的不想开始评判卡瑞尔离开后的版本。”好吧，他离开了。而迈克尔离开后，这部剧给人的第一个真正印象
of the show after Michael is a strong one. Yay. Many people called it the best episode of the series in years. I agree. I loved this episode. Same. And I listened to the DVD commentary for this episode, which features Ellie Kimper, Mindy Kaling, Steve Healy, Justin Spitzer, and myself. And we were all gushing about how everyone loved it, the cast, the crew, writers. We were all thrilled with this episode. This was a big bump in our confidence, this episode, because we felt like, oh, wait, maybe we can do this. Yeah. Fastback number two, OfficeTelly.com has a great interview with Rainn and Justin about this episode. It is really good. And in that interview, Justin was asked how he came up with the title of
非常深刻。耶。许多人称它是该剧近年来最好的一集。我同意。我很喜欢这一集。我也是。而且我听了这一集的DVD评论音轨，里面有艾莉·坎珀、曼迪·卡林、史蒂夫·希利、贾斯汀·斯皮策和我自己。我们当时都在滔滔不绝地谈论每个人有多么喜欢它，演员、剧组、编剧。我们所有人都为这一集欣喜若狂。这一集大大提振了我们的信心，因为我们觉得，哦，等等，也许我们能做到。耶。趣味冷知识二，OfficeTelly.com上有一篇关于雷恩和贾斯汀采访这一集的精彩报道。真的很棒。在那次采访中，贾斯汀被问到他是如何想出这一集的剧名，
this episode because it is very long. He explained that the working title for this script was Interim Manager. But that Mindy said that that was such a boring title that some Teavos might refuse to record it. She's not wrong. So when Justin sat down to write the script, he named it Dwight K. Schrute. Then he changed it to Dwight K. Schrute colon Interim Manager. But then he did some research and he realized that Dwight's actual title would be more of an acting manager. And he figured that Dwight would want to downplay the acting manager part. So that's why he put acting in parentheses. Look how much thought went into the title of this episode. Just the title. So much. Now, Fastback number three, everyone, buckle
因为这个名字真的很长。他解释说，这个剧本的暂定名是临时经理。但曼迪说这个名字太无聊了，以至于有些TiVo用户可能会拒绝录制它。她没说错。所以当贾斯汀坐下来写剧本时，他把它命名为德怀特·K·施鲁特。然后他把它改成了德怀特·K·施鲁特冒号临时经理。但后来他做了一些研究，意识到德怀特的真实头衔更应该是一个代理经理。他觉得德怀特会想淡化代理经理这部分。所以这就是为什么他把代理加上了括号。看看为这集剧名花了多少心思。仅仅是剧名。花了太多心思。现在，趣味冷知识三，各位，系好
in. It's a deep dive. Oh, I can't wait. Wait, I want to guess. I want to guess having watched the episode. It's going to be a deep dive on, um, well, I know the first one that comes to my mind. What's that? Either the samurai suit or the piranha or, um, wait, there's one other one. You said it. I said it. The samurai suit. Piranha. The piranha. In this episode Dwight, I can't wait. In this episode Dwight has a piranha in his office. I rewatched this episode with my daughter and my mother-in-law. Okay. And my mother-in-law, Lynn travels a lot and she said, that is not a piranha. And I was really, and I paused the TV and I said, what do you mean? She goes, I am telling you, it's not a piranha. I've seen a piranha
安全带。这是一次深度挖掘。哦，我等不及了。等等，我想猜一下。看过了这一集，我想猜一下。这将是对，嗯，好吧，我脑子里浮现的第一个是什么。是什么？要么是武士铠甲，要么是食人鱼，或者，嗯，等等，还有另一个。你说了。我说了。武士铠甲。食人鱼。食人鱼。在这集里，德怀特，我等不及了。在这集里，德怀特在他的办公室里养了一条食人鱼。我和我女儿还有我婆婆一起重温了这一集。好吧。我婆婆琳经常旅行，她说，那不是食人鱼。我当时真的很，我按了暂停键说，你什么意思？她说，我跟你说，那不是食人鱼。我见过食人鱼，
and that is not a piranha. They're smaller. And I said, Oh, well, I, I don't know. Well, Angela, Lynn is right. It is not a piranha in that tank. We could not have a real piranha because they are illegal to own in the state of California. Lynn, you knew it right away. Now they are legal in Pennsylvania. So it is okay for Dwight to have a piranha in his office. But Randy told us that our trainers were not licensed to have piranhas. You can only have them in like a research facility or like a controlled environment. Like there is, I guess, a piranha in the Monterey Bay Aquarium. But they are on the restricted animals list for California. By the way, I looked up what the other restricted animals are in California.
那绝对不是食人鱼。它们更小。我说，哦，好吧，我，我不知道。好吧，安吉拉，琳是对的。那个鱼缸里的不是食人鱼。我们不可能养一条真正的食人鱼，因为在加利福尼亚州拥有它们是违法的。琳，你一下子就认出来了。现在它们在宾夕法尼亚州是合法的。所以德怀特在他的办公室里养一条食人鱼是可以的。但兰迪告诉我们，我们的驯兽师没有饲养食人鱼的执照。你只能在诸如研究设施或受控环境中饲养它们。比如，我猜蒙特利湾水族馆里就有一条食人鱼。但它们在加州的受限制动物名单上。顺便说一句，我查了一下加州其他的受限制动物是什么。
I just got curious, like what else can you have? Can I guess? Can I guess? Sure. Let's see. Tiger. Well, that no one can have a tiger. Oh, okay. I mean, well, I've watched that Netflix show. They have a ton of them in Florida and Oklahoma. Oh, I guess that's true. Okay. Well, that wasn't on the list. Some type of snake? Also not on the list. No snakes? No, you can have a snake and a tiger. I guess. I don't know. Here's what's on the list. I'll stop guessing. As pets, you are not allowed to have a ferret, a mongoose, a bat, a bear, gerbils. Gerbils? Mm-hmm. I had gerbils growing up and I loved them. They were so sweet. Yeah. And I wanted to get my kids gerbils because I had such fond memories of having my gerbil.
我只是好奇，你还能养什么？我能猜吗？我能猜吗？当然。来看看。老虎。好吧，没有人能养老虎。哦，好吧，我是说，我看过那个网飞节目。他们在佛罗里达州和俄克拉荷马州养了一大堆。哦，我想那是真的。好吧，那不在名单上。某种蛇？也不在名单上。没有蛇？不，你可以养蛇和老虎。我想。我不知道。以下是名单上的内容。我不猜了。作为宠物，你不被允许养雪貂、猫鼬、蝙蝠、熊、沙鼠。沙鼠？嗯哼。我从小就养沙鼠，我很喜欢它们。它们太可爱了。是的。而且我想给我的孩子们买沙鼠，因为我对自己养的沙鼠有着非常美好的回忆。
Sure. Not in California. No, ma'am. What about hamster? Certain hamsters are allowed and certain are not. Okay. Also, you cannot own a monkey or a hedgehog. Who wants to own a hedgehog? They're very cute, but you should not own a hedgehog. Yeah. Let them live in the wild. They don't live their life. There's enough animals that already want to live with us. Yeah. Well, anyway, so also on that list, you can't have a piranha. So what they provided us with was a paku, which is a very similar species. It's also found in South America. Paku look very similar to piranha. Randy said it would take an expert to notice the difference. Lynn Snyder. Yes. Randy also shared with us that our head trainer Denise Sanders brought
当然。在加州不行。不行，女士。仓鼠呢？某些仓鼠是允许的，某些是不允许的。好吧。此外，你也不能养猴子或刺猬。谁想养刺猬？它们很可爱，但你不应该养刺猬。是的。让它们在大自然中生活吧。它们不习惯那种生活。已经有足够的动物想和我们一起生活了。是的。好吧，不管怎样，所以在这个名单上，你也不能养食人鱼。所以他们提供给我们的是一条淡水白鲳，这是一个非常相似的物种。它也产于南美洲。淡水白鲳看起来和食人鱼非常相似。兰迪说得专家才能看出区别。琳·斯奈德。是的。兰迪还跟我们分享说，我们的首席驯兽师丹尼斯·桑德斯带来
an assortment of tanks and water filtration warming systems and set them up backstage. I remember that. I do too. I remember the tanks of past fish. Yes. We had four identical looking paku. We used one on each day and the total cost for all the tanks, equipment, the paku and the trainers was $3,375. How do you train a paku? I don't know. I don't know. You have questions. I did not get that far into it, but I did not stop here. I did get curious about the piranha as a fish. Here's what I found out. I found out that while piranhas are dangerous and they can bite you if you're not careful, that idea that they just swim around in packs and eat a person to the bones, that's kind of a myth.
了各种各样的鱼缸和水过滤加温系统，并在后台把它们搭好了。我记得那个。我也记得。我记得过去那些鱼的鱼缸。是的。我们有四条长得一模一样的淡水白鲳。我们每天用一条，所有的鱼缸、设备、淡水白鲳和驯兽师的总费用是3375美元。你怎么训练一条淡水白鲳？我不知道。我不知道。你问题真多。我没有深入了解这个，但我并没有就此打住。我对食人鱼作为一种鱼类确实产生了好奇。这是我发现的。我发现，虽然食人鱼很危险，如果你不小心它们会咬你，但那种它们成群结队游动并把一个人啃得只剩白骨的想法，某种程度上是个神话。
Sounds like a cartoon. Yes. Piranha are actually really timid. They're kind of nervous. The reason that they swim altogether, it's not because they're like pack hunters. It's because they feel safe. That's why most little fish swim in big groups. Yeah. Exactly. However, splashing attracts piranha. I did not know this. This is why they think that maybe children get bitten more often because they're splashing. Also, if you're swimming in an area that might have piranha, don't swim near fishermen because the flapping of the fish that they're catching attracts piranha. Just a hot tip for you if you're in a piranha stream or possible piranha stream. That said, people have been killed
听起来像个动画片。是的。食人鱼其实非常胆小。它们有点神经质。它们聚在一起游动，不是因为它们像群居猎手。是因为它们觉得安全。这就是大多数小鱼游成大群的原因。是的。完全正确。然而，水花四溅会吸引食人鱼。我以前不知道这一点。这就是为什么他们认为也许小孩子们被咬得更多，因为他们在戏水。此外，如果你在可能有食人鱼的区域游泳，千万不要在渔夫附近游泳，因为他们捕获的鱼拍打水面会吸引食人鱼。这只是给身处食人鱼溪流或可能是食人鱼溪流中的你的一条实用小贴士。话虽如此，人们确实曾被食人鱼
by piranha. It happens. It is not common, but I did get curious about what animal kills the most people each year. This took a turn. I did not see coming. Listen, I got so curious. I was like, what animals can I not own? What animals are most dangerous? All right. Wait, I want to guess again, and I want to think outside the box here. I don't want to go with what might be some obvious choices. Also, I want to say, here's just a little hint. The term animal, it's a very loose term. You could include humans. Well, that's on the list. Oh. Humans is the second most dangerous thing to humans, but there is something that is the most dangerous thing to humans. More dangerous than a human. And it's more of an
杀死过。这种事会发生。这并不常见，但我确实很好奇每年究竟是什么动物杀死了最多的人。这件事有了个转折。我完全没料到。听着，我太好奇了。我想，有哪些动物是我不能养的？哪些动物最危险？好吧。等等，我想再猜一次，我想跳出常规来思考。我不想选那些可能很显而易见的选项。另外，我要说的是，这里有个小提示。“动物”这个词，是个非常宽泛的词。你可以把人类包括在内。好吧，这在名单上。哦。人类是对人类第二危险的事物，但有一种东西是对人类最危险的事物。比人类更危险。而且它更像是一种
insect. It kills more people each year. Mosquito? Yes. Yes. You gave me a lot of clues. I did. You gave me a lot of clues. Mosquitoes carry life-threatening diseases, and those diseases kill about three quarters of a million people every year. Then the next dangerous thing to humans is humans. Number three, wild boar? Number three is the freshwater snail. What? Yeah. They also carry disease. Is wild boar on this list anywhere? It is not. Okay. But beware of a saw-scaled viper and assassin bug. The assassin bug, listen to this, they're also sometimes called the kissing bug because they come and bite your face while you're sleeping and then you die of a disease. No, thank you. Scorpions, roundworms, the saltwater
昆虫。它每年杀死的人更多。蚊子？是的。是的，你给了我很多线索。我是给的。你给了我很多线索。蚊子携带危及生命的疾病，这些疾病每年夺走大约七十五万人的生命。然后对人类第二危险的事物就是人类。第三名，野猪？第三名是淡水螺。什么？是的。它们也携带疾病。野猪在这个名单上的任何地方吗？没有。好吧。但要当心锯鳞蝰和猎蝽。猎蝽，听着，它们有时也被称为接吻虫，因为它们会在你睡觉时来咬你的脸，然后你会死于某种疾病。不用了，谢谢。蝎子、蛔虫、咸水
crocodile, elephants, and hippos. Those are the top 10 things that kill people every year. So just to say, Dwight does have a dangerous animal in his office, but it's not as dangerous as some things he could have in his office, not even as dangerous as Dwight himself. True. As this episode will prove. Assassin bug. That's gonna keep me up at night. Bite your face. One time I was visiting my grandparents' small town, Texas, and there was this bug and my cousin was like, don't step on that. That's a blister bug. I was like, what is a blister bug? And she's like, you step on it and it's butt like pops and then it gives you a blister. What? I'm just telling you. Just telling you. Wow. Also, they had stink
鳄鱼、大象和河马。这些是每年杀死人类最多的前十名。所以我想说的是，德怀特在他的办公室里确实养了一只危险的动物，但它并没有他办公室里可能养的一些东西那么危险，甚至没有德怀特本人那么危险。确实如此。正如这一集将要证明的那样。猎蝽。这会让我在晚上睡不着觉的。咬你的脸。有一次我拜访我祖父母在得克萨斯州的小镇，那里有一只虫子，我表弟说，别踩那个。那是水疱虫。我说，什么是水疱虫？她说，你一踩它，它的屁股就会“砰”地爆开，然后你就会起水疱。什么？我只是告诉你。只是告诉你。哇。另外，它们还有臭
bugs. Well, I've heard of a stink bug. They're stinky. They're stinky. Well, listen, that's all I got. Should we take a break? Yes, because then I want to get into this episode. I really want to talk about what Dwight wants to give as a gift for DeAngelo. Yes, please. We are back and we are in the conference room. A few of the employees are brainstorming gift ideas for DeAngelo. I was thrilled this day because I got to be in a scene with you. I know. And we got to be chatty between takes. Here's what everyone is brainstorming. Jim thinks they should get baskets full of chocolates, teddy bears, balloons, stuff like that, right? Yes. I mean, DeAngelo is in the hospital. Dwight says, no, no, no. I want to do the
虫。好吧，我听说过臭虫。它们很臭。它们很臭。好吧，听着，我说的就这么多了。我们该休息一下吗？是的，因为接下来我想聊聊这一集。我真的很想谈谈德怀特想给德安吉洛送什么礼物。好的，请吧。我们回来了，现在我们在会议室里。几个员工正在为德安吉洛头脑风暴礼物创意。我今天超级兴奋，因为我有机会和你演对手戏。我知道。而且我们在拍摄间隙聊得很开心。以下是大家的头脑风暴。吉姆认为他们应该买装满巧克力的篮子、泰迪熊、气球之类的一大堆东西，对吧？是的。我是说，德安吉洛在医院里。德怀特说，不，不，不。我想送
knapsack filled with canned goods, chainsaw, gasoline, and emergency radio in case he wakes up post-apocalypse. I just want to say something. If I were in a coma and I woke up and one of my gifts was what Dwight described, that would be so funny to me. I would absolutely love that person who sent that with a card that said, in case you wake up post-apocalypse, we wanted you to be prepared. Please, if I'm ever in a coma, put this gift in my room. I will appreciate it. Two things with this sentence. It's funny to me. Two things. One, you think you're going to wake up out of a coma with a really good sense of humor? This will give me a boost. The other thing is, Dwight isn't being funny. I know. He's being
装有罐头食品、链锯、汽油和紧急收音机的背包，以防他在世界末日后醒来。我只想说一说。如果我昏迷了，醒来后收到德怀特所说的这种礼物，我会觉得这太好笑了。我一定会非常喜欢那个送这个礼物并附上一张卡片的人，卡片上写着：以防你在世界末日后醒来，我们希望你做好准备。拜访一下，如果我以后昏迷了，请把这个礼物放在我的房间里。我会感激的。关于这句话有两点。这对我来说很好笑。两点。第一，你觉得你从昏迷中醒来时会有一种很好的幽默感吗？这会给我打气。另一点是，德怀特并不是在搞笑。我知道。他是认真的
for real. But when you think about it, if you wake up out of a coma and there's a balloon that's been deflated and chocolates that have gone bad. That's what I'm saying. Flowers are dead. I just think it's a very fun, like, post-coma gag gift. Well, I know you're not watching The Last of Us yet because you told me to stop telling you stuff about it. I'm not going to say a word. We're going to start. We're starting this weekend. We have an overnight date night. We are bringing our Apple TV so that we can binge this show. I can't wait. I will get caught up. I need you to talk to me after. Okay. I think about Dwight a lot series The Last of Us. Jim has a talking head next and he's outside. He's talking about how
当你想想看，如果你从昏迷中醒来，有一个已经漏气的气球和变质的巧克力。这就是我想说的。花都枯死了。我只是觉得这非常有趣，就像是一个昏迷后的恶作剧礼物。好吧，我知道你还没看《最后生还者》，因为你叫我不要再跟你剧透了。我不会说一个字。我们要开始了。我们这周末开始看。我们有个过夜约会。我们要带上 Apple TV，这样我们就可以狂刷这部剧了。我等不及了。我会赶上进度的。我需要你在看完之后和我聊聊。好的。我经常想起德怀特，还有《最后生还者》这部剧。接下来吉姆有一个单人访谈，他在外面。他谈到
it turns out that they never got a manager because you don't need one. People just come in and do the work on their own schedules and it's been really great. Everyone's happy. They put a foosball machine in Michael's old office. We got a fan question from Stephanie W. in Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania, who said, not a question, but an observation. In the cold open of this episode, when Jim explains that it turns out they don't need a manager, I found this interesting and wonder if that's why this branch has always been successful. Are they used to not being managed at all under Michael Scott? That is an excellent observation. Well, Jim is going to get a phone call from Joe and we can only hear his side of the conversation, but it's clear that she has asked him to be the acting
事实证明，他们从来没有找过经理，因为你根本不需要经理。人们只是按照自己的时间表进来工作，这真的很好。每个人都很高兴。他们在迈克尔的旧办公室里放了一台桌上足球。我们收到了来自宾夕法尼亚州匹兹堡的史黛西·W的粉丝提问，她说，这不是一个问题，而是一个观察。在本集的开头，当吉姆解释说他们其实不需要经理时，我发现这很有趣，并想知道这就是为什么这个分公司在迈克尔·斯科特的管理下一直很成功的原因吗？他们是不是习惯了在迈克尔·斯科特手下完全不受管理？这是一个绝佳的观察。好吧，吉姆将接到乔的电话，我们只能听到他这一端的对话，但很明显，乔要求他担任代理
manager and he says, no, we don't need one. And then immediately Dwight's phone rings and you can tell Joe is asking him the same question and he accepts wholeheartedly. And Pam is like, what have you done, Jim? What have you done? I mean, it's very similar to when Jim would not pick a health care plan and it went to Dwight. Yes. Jim, what did you think was going to happen? Dwight could not be more excited. He goes into the office, he sits down at his desk and he makes a phone call. He says, Moes, you'll never guess where I am right now. And then you hear Moes yell. He knows immediately. He's so happy. We had a fan question from Aiden W. in Portland, Oregon. In this cold open, when Dwight calls Moes, please tell me this is
经理，而他说，不，我们不需要。然后紧接着德怀特的电话就响了，你能听出来乔也在问他同样的问题，而他欣然接受了。帕姆就像是在说，你做了什么，吉姆？你做了什么？我的意思是，这非常类似于当初吉姆不肯选择医疗保险计划，结果落到了德怀特头上。是的。吉姆，你觉得接下来会发生什么？德怀特兴奋极了。他走进办公室，坐在办公桌前，打了个电话。他说，莫斯，你永远不会猜到我现在在哪里。然后你就能听到莫斯在大喊。他立刻就知道了。他太高兴了。我们收到了来自俄勒冈州波特兰市艾丹·W的粉丝提问。在这个开头，当德怀特打电话给莫斯时，请告诉我这是
a reference to the final scene in Working Girl. Oh, Sam, guess where I am? And then her friend is like standing up and just screaming, just screaming. I asked Justin Spitzer if this was a nod to Working Girl and he said yes 100%. Oh my gosh. Yeah, which is so cool. That is awesome. We also had a fan question from Jessica P. in Cornwall, Ontario, Canada, who said, who voiced Moes's ah when Dwight calls to tell him about the manager position? Guys, that was Mike Scherr. Yeah. He came and did some ADR work just to scream into a microphone for this one bit.
对电影《打工女郎》最后一幕的致敬？哦，萨姆，猜猜我在哪儿？然后她的朋友就站起来尖叫，狂叫。我问了贾斯汀·斯皮策这是否是在向《打工女郎》致敬，他说100%是。哦天哪。是的，太酷了。这太棒了。我们还收到了来自加拿大安大略省康沃尔的杰西卡·P的粉丝提问，她说，当德怀特打电话告诉莫斯经理职位时，是谁给莫斯配的“啊”的声音？伙计们，那是迈克·舒尔。是的。他来做了一些对白后期的配音工作，只是为了对着麦克风尖叫一下。
He has a very funny answer to this question in that Office Telly interview that you're talking about. He does. If you guys go read it, it's very funny. The show is going to open with Jim and Pam. They're arriving for work. Only Pam gets out of the car. Jim does not want to go in. He's going to sit in the car all day, apparently. Jim is going to have a talking head where he describes what it's been like to have Dwight as the acting manager for one week. I mean, it feels like three months. There's all of these new policies, new rules, like they have to punch in on an old time, time clock.
他在你提到的那次《Office Telly》采访中对这个问题有一个非常有趣的回答。他确实有。如果你们去读读看，非常有趣。节目将以吉姆和帕姆的到来开场。只有帕姆下了车。吉姆不想进去。他显然打算整天坐在车里。吉姆将有一个单人访谈，他在访谈中描述了让德怀特担任代理经理一周是什么感觉。我的意思是，感觉就像已经过了三个月。这里有所有这些新政策、新规，比如他们必须在一台老式打卡机上打卡。
I listed every single new rule that I could find in the shooting draft. Oh, really? Yes. Are you going to give it to us? Do you want to hear it now? Please. Please. I want to tell you too that Mindy shared on the commentary how much fun it was in the writer's room to pitch all the different ways that Dwight's new office would run. Okay. Here were the rules I found in the shooting draft. There's probably more. I might have missed some.
我把我在拍摄剧本中能找到的每一条新规定都列出来了。哦，真的吗？是的。你要告诉我们吗？你现在想听吗？请吧。请。我还想告诉你，明迪在评论中分享了编剧室里构思德怀特新办公室运作的各种方式时是多么有趣。好吧。这是我在拍摄剧本中找到的规则。可能还有更多。我可能漏掉了一些。
Number one, like you said, they have to punch into a very ye olde time clock. Now, I remember something about that time clock. It did not work. No. You guys were fakey. And Angela, your fakey is so good. You like, I just want everyone to know like that sound, like that, that was in post production. That machine did nothing. Nothing.
第一条，就像你说的，他们必须在一台非常古老的打卡机上打卡。现在，我记得关于那个打卡机的一些事。它根本不好使。没有。你们是在假装。安吉拉，你假装得太好了。你就像，我只想让所有人知道，那个声音，那个，是在后期制作中加的。那台机器根本没用。一点用没有。
So you like flinching and then like your card gets a little bit. It was so good. That's just Angela acting. Thank you. Apparently, I'm really good with a fake time clock. Okay. So then here's another rule. Everyone got new business cards, but none of them fit in their wallets. And they're all referred to as junior employees. You see a shot of Jim trying to put that card in his wallet. And we did have a fan catch from Grace E. and Rochester, New York,
所以你就像是畏缩了一下，然后你的卡就有点。太棒了。这纯粹是安吉拉的演技。谢谢。显然，我真的很擅长对着一个假打卡机演戏。好吧。那么还有一条规则。每个人都拿到了新名片，但没有一张能放进钱包里。而且他们都被称为初级员工。你可以看到一个镜头是吉姆试图把那张卡塞进钱包里。我们确实收到了来自纽约州罗切斯特市格蕾丝·E的粉丝抓包，
who wanted to point out the Wegmans grocery card that was also in Jim's wallet. I saw that too. All of their lunch breaks are staggered to prevent wasting time. No one gets to eat together. No. They have the pledge of allegiance every morning. Then there are morning announcements. Everyone has also been given a 21 digit number
她想指出吉姆钱包里还装着韦格曼斯超市卡。我也看到了。他们的午餐时间是错开的，以防浪费时间。谁也不准一起吃饭。没有。他们每天早晨都要宣誓效忠。然后是早间广播。每个人还被分配了一个21位数字的
copier code that you cannot share. I'm going to get to that. That's one of my favorite scenes I've ever done. I watched it several times because it was such perfection. I can't wait to share about it. Also, you cannot be late. Coffee is 50 cents and he's installed security cameras in the kitchen to spy on everyone. There is no food in the break room vending machines,
复印机密码，并且绝对不能共享。我等会儿会讲到这个。这是我做过的最喜欢的场景之一。我看了好几遍，因为这简直太完美了。我等不及要分享了。还有，你不能迟到。咖啡50美分，他在厨房里安装了监控摄像头来监视所有人。休息室的自动售货机里没有食物，
just advertisements for caffeine corner. The computers have internet blockers and there's no more voicemails because Dwight doesn't trust a robot to give you your messages. I mean, I think you pretty much summed it up. So Jim lays a lot of those new rules out in his talking head. And speaking of that talking head, we had a fan question from Laura M in Toronto, Canada. At two minutes four seconds when Jim is outside, we can see his breath.
只有咖啡因角落的广告。电脑有互联网拦截器，而且再也没有语音留言了，因为德怀特不信任机器人来传达你的留言。我的意思是，我想你基本上已经概括了。所以吉姆在他的单人访谈中列举了许多新规定。说到那个单人访谈，我们收到了来自加拿大多伦多的劳拉·M的粉丝提问。在两分零四秒时，当吉姆在外面时，我们可以看到他的呼气。
How did you achieve this since it's always so warm in LA? Well, Randy said that we shot this scene first thing in the morning. On day one, it was Monday, March 28th, 2011. March 28th, I mean, that's usually pleasant. But Randy said that our call sheet said that the overnight low was about 49 degrees, which still seems pretty warm to see breath vapor. But Randy said there is no note of having like added that in post. Justin Spitzer did an interview where he said, it's real.
既然洛杉矶总是那么暖和，你们是怎么做到这一点的？兰迪说我们是一大早拍摄这场戏的。第一天，那是2011年3月28日，星期一。3月28日，我的意思是，那通常很舒适。但兰迪说我们的通告单上显示夜间最低温度大约是49华氏度，这看起来仍然相当温暖，不至于能看到呼出的水汽。但兰迪说没有任何关于在后期添加这个特效的记录。贾斯汀·斯皮策接受了一次采访，他说，这是真的。
It was really that cold. Well, I can tell you, I was there that morning. I was there that morning. That's right. I worked right after John. That's, I think, when we did the clock thing. See, I had no memory of being outside. I'm outside in that scene.
当时真的有那么冷。好吧，我可以告诉你，那天早上我在场。那天早上我在场。没错。我在约翰之后马上就开工了。我想那就是我们做打卡机那场戏的时候。你看，我对在外面拍戏一点记忆都没有。我在那个场景里是在外面的。
I'm at the car and then I'm in the background. We shot all that stuff on the same day. I have no memory of it being cold. Isn't that weird? You'd think I would remember. You'd think. I share on the commentary that I was freezing that morning, that we had had a cold snap.
我在车旁边，然后我在背景里。我们把所有这些镜头都在同一天拍完了。我不记得当时很冷了。这不是很奇怪吗？你本以为我会记得的。你本以为会。我在评论里分享过，那天早上我冻僵了，我们遇到了一股寒流。
And that was just a real chilly morning. So, fakey time clock, real breath vapor. And real baby belly. My baby belly catch. Go two, three minutes, 11 seconds when Pam yells, stop stalling. I'll see you, baby bulb. Well, this is the episode where I described in our book that I had gone to J.Crew over the weekend
那真的是一个寒冷的早晨。所以，假打卡机，真呼气水汽。还有真的孕肚。我的孕肚抓包。到两分三分十一秒，当帕姆大喊，别拖延了。回见，小不点。好吧，这就是我在我们的书中描述过的那一集，我周末去了 J.Crew
and bought myself a new outfit because I realized I was not going to make it to the end of the season in my wardrobe. You were busting out of your button down Pam shirt. So much. And you tried to hide it. I did. And three minutes, 11 seconds.
给自己买了一套新衣服，因为我意识到我的衣服撑不到这一季结束了。你把帕姆的衬衫纽扣都快撑爆了。太厉害了。而且你还试图藏起来。我确实藏了。在三分十一秒。
It made me smile, Jenna. I was like, oh, it's my little boy in there. I know. Well, now we're going to see the bullpen under Dwight's supervision. I went to the shooting draft to see how it was described. Okay. Interior office reception.
这让我笑了，珍娜。我想，哦，里面是我的小男孩。我懂。好吧，现在我们要看看德怀特监督下的办公区了。我去翻了拍摄剧本，看看它是怎么描述的。好的。室内，办公室，前台。
People are walking in for the day. Stanley punches in and walks past an American flag in a framed portrait of Dwight. And he at his desk takes off his windbreaker, revealing he is wearing a short sleeve shirt like the one Dwight wears. We hear the beep of a watch alarm coming from what is now Dwight's office.
人们走进来开始一天的工作。斯坦利打卡上班，走过一面美国国旗和一幅德怀特的装裱画像。他在办公桌旁脱下防风夹克，露出他穿着一件短袖衬衫，就像德怀特穿的那种。我们听到从现在的德怀特办公室传来手表的闹钟蜂鸣声。
Dwight walks out with a smile. He kicks the front door shut and says, let's begin. So I noticed a couple of things in this scene. First of all, at four minutes, when Dwight walks up to start to lead everyone in the Pledge of Allegiance, followed by his morning announcements, there's a shot of the messages container.
德怀特微笑着走了出来。他一脚把前门踢上，说，开始吧。所以我在这个场景中注意到了一些事情。首先，在四分钟时，当德怀特走过来开始带领大家宣誓效忠，接着是他的早间广播时，镜头扫过了留言容器。
You know, the thing is on reception. DeAngelo Vickers is still getting messages. His name is still on the little message thing. We also got a fan question from Steven M. in San Francisco who said, I noticed that Andy was wearing a short sleeve business suit. Was this a nod to his usual sucking up to the manager by replicating Dwight's style choices?
你知道的，前台那个东西。迪安吉洛·维克斯仍然有留言。他的名字还在那个小留言条上。我们还收到了来自旧金山的史蒂芬·M的粉丝提问，他说，我注意到安迪穿着短袖商务西装。这是否是在效仿德怀特的着装风格，以此来拍经理的马屁？
Yes. So we shot that little moment of him taking off his windbreaker and then Dwight clocks it. And when they did their writers screening, because they would do that, they would screen the episodes for the writers while they were editing. He said it got a huge laugh in the room,
是的。所以我们拍摄了那个他脱下防风夹克的小片段，然后德怀特注意到了。当他们进行编剧审片时，因为他们会这样做，他们会在剪辑时为编剧们放映剧集。他说这在房间里引起了哄堂大笑，
but ultimately it had to get cut for time. So then you just see Andy wearing the short sleeve shirt and it's not really explained. It's now time for everyone to say the Pledge of Allegiance. Behind Dwight is a huge painting of himself looking like a dictator. Angela is very into this Pledge of Allegiance. She's kind of into this whole mood, I think.
但最终为了时长不得不被剪掉了。所以你只能看到安迪穿着短袖衬衫，并没有真正解释原因。现在是大家宣誓效忠的时候了。德怀特身后是一幅巨大的他自己的画像，看起来像个独裁者。安吉拉非常投入这个效忠宣誓。我想她对这种整体氛围很投入。
I think she is, too. We got a bunch of fan mail about you, Angela, in this Pledge of Allegiance. People want to know if your amen was scripted or improvised. Y'all, I improvised that. I was so delighted it made it in. We also got a fan question from David P. in Pennsylvania who noticed that Oscar does not say
我想她也是。我们收到了很多关于你的粉丝来信，安吉拉，关于你在这场效忠宣誓中的表现。人们想知道你的“阿门”是剧本里写的还是即兴发挥的。大家，那是即兴发挥的。我很高兴它最终被播出了。我们还收到了来自宾夕法尼亚州大卫·P的粉丝提问，他注意到奥斯卡没有说
one nation under God. And he even gives a look to camera. Wanted to know if that was scripted. That was scripted. Justin said he heard that some people thought that this implied that Oscar is an atheist, but that was not Justin's intention. He said he just figured that Oscar was the kind of guy
“同一个上帝之下的国家”。而且他甚至还朝镜头看了一眼。想知道这是否是剧本安排的。那是剧本安排的。贾斯汀说他听说有些人认为这暗示奥斯卡是个无神论者，但这并非贾斯汀的本意。他说他只是觉得奥斯卡是那种
who would resent being made to talk about God in the workplace and he would very proudly and very smugly publicly abstain. And so that's why he wrote that bit. I bet Oscar has that actually ready to go. Exactly. In the morning announcements, Dwight is gonna let everyone know about the copier codes
会对被迫在工作场所谈论上帝感到不满的人，而且他会非常自豪、非常自鸣得意地公开弃权。所以这就是他写这一段的原因。我敢打赌奥斯卡其实已经准备好这么做了。没错。在早间广播中，德怀特将让所有人知道复印机密码，
and also that Joe Bennett is coming for a high level meeting between him and Gabe. And by high level, it's just a general meet and greet. Kelly is going to be late. She comes in like a back door. Sneaky. How often is she late? If she always comes in that back door,
并且乔·贝内特将为他和加布之间的高层会议而来。所谓的高层，其实只是一个普通的见面会。凯利要迟到了。她像从后门一样溜进来。鬼鬼祟祟的。她到底有多经常迟到？如果她总是走那个后门，
you know Michael wasn't looking for her. I don't think we've ever used that door. Well, she said she had an illness of a personal nature and Dwight wants to know which part of her body. Mindy could not keep this together. No. She was laughing so hard. Every single time.
你知道迈克尔当时根本没在找她。我觉得我们从来没用过那扇门。好吧，她说她得了私密性的疾病，而德怀特想知道是她身体的哪个部位。明迪根本憋不住。没有。她笑得太厉害了。每一次都是。
As he was like pointing. Yes. And I'm surprised they even got a take without her laughing. Now we're gonna start this Gabe Andy runner where Gabe is just trying so desperately to win Aaron back and he doesn't want Andy flirting with her. No, he grabs Andy and brings him into the conference room and they close all the blinds.
当他指着的时候。是的。我很惊讶他们甚至在没有她笑场的情况下拍完了一条。现在我们要开始加布和安迪这条线了，加布拼命地想要赢回艾琳，而且他不想让安迪调戏她。没有，他抓住安迪把他拉进会议室，然后关上了所有的百叶窗。
I loved this spy shot through the blinds. There is only a two inch space. You see the whole scene play out in two inches. Basically he makes Andy promise to never date Aaron again. Makes him say it. And he's so overbearing that Andy kind of agrees. He just wants out of there. Andy's like get me out of this conference room.
我很喜欢透过百叶窗拍的这个偷窥镜头。只有两英寸宽的缝隙。你通过这两英寸看到了整个场景的展开。基本上他让安迪保证再也不跟艾琳约会了。逼他说出来。而且他太霸道了，安迪只好答应了。他只想离开那里。安迪就像是在说，快把我弄出这个会议室。
In the meantime, Jim has started his sabotaging of Dwight. Mm-hmm. You know, there are a bunch of deleted scenes on the DVD where he gets Jordan to prank Dwight with him. And Jenna, it did not sit well with me. No. I was like, why is Jordan pranking Dwight with you and not Pam?
与此同时，吉姆开始了他对德怀特的破坏活动。嗯哼。你知道，DVD上有好几个删减片段，里面他让乔丹跟他一起恶作剧整德怀特。珍娜，这让我很不舒服。没有。我在想，为什么是乔丹跟你一起恶作剧整德怀特，而不是帕姆？
I didn't like it and I'm glad they were deleted. Well, I remember seeing an early cut of this episode and there was a talking head with Jordan. Yeah. Where she says something to the effect of like, well, there's one person in the office, I don't mind. Or something like that. Oh no.
我不喜欢这样，而且我很庆幸这些片段被删了。好吧，我记得看过这一集的早期剪辑版，里面有一个乔丹的单人访谈。是的。她在里面说了类似这样的话，嗯，办公室里有一个人，我不介意。诸如此类的话。哦，不。
Jim after this day of pranking. It's on the DVDs and she smiles and lights up and looks so beautiful. And she's so like tickled by Jim. And I was like, uh-uh. That would have made people lose their minds. Yeah, that all went. Goodbye.
吉姆在经历了这一天的恶作剧之后。这在DVD上可以看到，她微笑着，眼睛亮了起来，看起来美极了。而且她对吉姆感到非常开心。当时我就想，呃-呃。那会让大家大跌眼镜的。是的，那些都被删了。再见。
Well, Jim is going to try to start a social club called The Fist. Mm-hmm. Dwight sees this, of course, as a rebellion. Jim says, listen, I'd love to have you come in today, but it's just that today we're really busy with Operation Overthrow. Mm-hmm.
好吧，吉姆将试图发起一个名为“拳头”的社交俱乐部。嗯哼。德怀特当然把这视为一种叛乱。吉姆说，听着，我很想让你今天来，但只是今天我们真的很忙，在忙“推翻行动”。嗯哼。
It's not a big deal, but. What was Jim's morning like? He wouldn't come inside, then he did come inside, then he made a whole bunch of flyers. Yeah. He used a lot of black ink. He did. He's been very busy at the copier.
这没什么大不了的，但是。吉姆的早晨是怎样的？他本来不肯进来，后来进来了，然后做了好大一堆传单。是的。他用了大量的黑墨水。确实。他在复印机旁忙坏了。
Oh. Why wasn't he at the copier? I don't know. Well, Angela is stuck behind Kevin at the copier as he tries to type in his 21 digit copy code. This was one of my favorite scenes to do in all of season seven. I loved doing this bit with Craig and Brian.
哦。他为什么不在复印机旁？我不知道。好吧，安吉拉被凯文堵在了复印机后面，因为凯文正试图输入他那21位数的复印密码。这是我在整个第七季中最喜欢拍的场景之一。我太喜欢跟克雷格和布莱恩一起拍这场戏了。
We were having the absolute time of our lives, and it's going to come back later, and I'll share more then. Well, I have a fan catch from Shanley S. in Anchorage, Alaska at six minutes and 40 seconds. You can see a Solitaire game on the computer screen behind Kevin when he's at the copier. So not everyone was worried about the copier.
我们度过了绝对最美妙的时光，后面还会有相关的剧情，到时我会分享更多。好吧，我收到了来自阿拉斯加州安克雷格的香利·S在6分40秒处的粉丝抓包。当凯文在复印机旁时，你可以在他身后的电脑屏幕上看到一局纸牌游戏。所以并不是每个人都在担心复印机。
Some people were playing Solitaire. Well, Andy is now going to try to show Pam a video, and it's blocked. The website is blocked. Mm-hmm. The internet blocked. This was a bigger runner, and it was driving everyone crazy because Dwight limited their internet access.
有些人还在玩纸牌。好吧，安迪现在要试图给帕姆看一段视频，但被屏蔽了。网址被屏蔽了。嗯哼。互联网被拦截了。这是一个更大的支线剧情，把所有人都逼疯了，因为德怀特限制了他们的互联网访问。
Phyllis was really struggling with it. She was trying to remember a movie. She was trying to tell everyone about it. It's in the deleted scenes, and I kind of need you to hear it. Well, maybe we should talk to Joe. And say what? Joe, Dwight won't let us watch sneezing animal videos online anymore.
菲利斯真的很难受。她一直在努力回想一部电影。她试图把这事告诉所有人。这在删减片段里，我有点需要你听听看。好吧，也许我们应该跟乔谈谈。然后说什么？乔，德怀特不让我们在网上看动物打喷嚏的视频了。
Fire him. No, Pam, this is our life now. Mindless drones working for a machine. It's just like that movie. What is that movie with that actor? He's in that one big movie with that lady. The one with the lady? Yeah, and then one really huge movie with that black actor
开除他。不，帕姆，这就是我们现在的生活。像机器一样的无脑机器人。就像那部电影一样。那个男演员演的那部是什么电影？他和那个女演员一起演过一部大片。和那个女演员吗？对，然后还有一部和那个黑人演员合作的超级大片，
who's been in a bunch of things. Is he black? No, no, no. He's not black. He's the one who, oh my god. This is why we need the internet. I'm going bonkers. I can't.
那个演过很多作品的演员。他是黑人吗？不，不，不。他不是黑人。他是那个，哦天哪。这就是为什么我们需要互联网。我要发疯了。我受不了了。
Oh my god. I know. She's like, I can't take it. She kind of trails off. And then later, Dwight finally lets everyone have internet. And Phyllis, I think, does Googling, Jenna. She Googles? I think she Googles, because then she has a talking head.
哦天哪。我知道。她就像是，我受不了了。她的话渐渐说不下去了。然后过了一会儿，德怀特终于让所有人都可以上网了，菲利斯，我觉得，她在用谷歌搜索，珍娜。她在谷歌搜索？我觉得她在搜索，因为随后她有一个单人访谈。
And guess the actor she was trying to think of? I don't know. It was Keanu Reeves. Ah! Oh my god! It was Keanu! Yes, when Oscar says we're just like mindless drones working, she was thinking of the Matrix.
猜猜她一直在努力想的那个演员是谁？我不知道。是基努·里维斯。啊！哦天哪！是基努！是的，当奥斯卡说我们就像工作的无脑机器人时，她想的是《黑客帝国》。
At least that's what I think. Oh my god. Yeah. Keanu is always popping up in our lives. His name was literally said on our set. I feel like that is all we need for him to come be a guest, even though he was in a deleted talking head. He is part of the office world.
至少我是这么觉得的。哦天哪。是的。基努总是出现在我们的生活中。我们的剧组里真的有人说出他的名字。我觉得这就是他来当嘉宾所需要的一切，尽管他是在一个被删掉的单人访谈里提到的。他是办公室世界的一部分。
He is. He's part of the crew. Keanu, Keanu, would you come? Maybe we'll break down speed, and you could sit with us and tell us what it was like to do speed. Just come here. Just come hang out, Keanu. We'll have snacks.
他是。他是剧组的一员。基努，基努，你会来吗？也许我们可以分析一下《生死时速》，然后你可以跟我们坐在一起，告诉我们拍《生死时速》是什么感觉。来这里吧。来跟我们一起玩吧，基努。我们会有零食的。
Wow. I know. He was on the office. He was on the office. I flipped out. I had to play it for you. This is going to lead now to a Dwight talking head. He says, you know what?
哇。我知道。他曾在《办公室》里出现过。他曾在《办公室》里出现过。我当时惊呆了。我不得不放给你听。这接下来将引出一个德怀特的单人访谈。他说，你知道吗？
I will never be happier than I am right now. He is so happy to be the Dundermifling acting manager. Yeah. He's sitting in his office at his giant desk. You know, Mindy and Justin talked about how much fun it was to pitch what all would be on Dwight's desk. I loved his office, and I loved the care
我永远不会比现在更快乐了。他能成为办公室代理经理感到高兴极了。是的。他坐在办公室的巨大办公桌前。你知道的，明迪和贾斯汀谈到构思德怀特办公桌上应该摆些什么时是多么有趣。我喜欢他的办公室，我也喜欢他们
that they had so clearly taken in decorating it. In deleted scenes, Jenna, Dwight gives the documentary crew a very big tour of his office. Really? He goes through every part of it. He points out a framed 3D velvet wolf picture. Incredible. 3D.
在装饰它时显然所倾注的心血。在删减片段里，珍娜，德怀特带着纪录片摄制组对他的办公室进行了一次非常详细的参观。真的吗？他把里面的每个角落都介绍了一遍。他指着一幅装裱好的3D立体天鹅绒狼图。太不可思议了。3D的。
I wish I had it. He also points out his samurai armor that's in the corner. And there were a bunch of swords as well. Jenna, he has like a dagger letter opener. And he can really open letters with it, but he could also, you know, stab someone with it. Sure. Yeah.
我要是能有这个就好了。他还指出了角落里的武士铠甲。里面还有一堆宝剑。珍娜，他有一把像匕首一样的拆信刀。他真的可以用它来拆信，但你也可以，你知道的，用它捅死某人。当然。是的。
A Spartan mask, a fake fireplace, the piranha we've talked about, the Beaumont Adams. He says it's over 120 years old. And they also shared in the commentary that at one point Dwight improvised, as he's giving this tour, putting on the samurai armor. OK. And the props department freaked out
一个斯巴达面具，一个假壁炉，我们之前聊过的食人鱼，还有博蒙特亚当斯手枪。他说这枪有120多年的历史了。他们还在评论中分享说，有一次德怀特在进行这次参观时，即兴发挥穿上了武士铠甲。好吧。道具部门当时都吓坏了
because they had rented it, and it cost like $10,000. Oh my gosh. It was so expensive. Wow. Yeah. And when rain started pretending to put it on, they were like, blah, blah, blah, stop, stop. If you want to see the tour of Dwight's office,
因为他们租了这个，花了大约10,000美元。天哪。太贵了。哇。是的。当雷恩假装要把它们戴上时，他们说，啦啦啦，停，停。如果你想参观德怀特的办公室，
go to the DVD extras. Well, Jenna, before we go to break, I want to show you what this framed 3D velvet wolf poster looked like. I took a screen grab of it. I'll put it in stories. It's haunting. I know.
去看DVD花絮。好了，珍娜，在我们休息之前，我想让你们看看这张带框的3D绒毛狼海报是什么样子的。我截了张图。我会把它发到快拍里。太诡异了。我知道。
That would terrify me if that was in my home. It's super creepy. Or any room I'm in. I know. And I thought I wanted to live up to my dundee of bringing in visuals onto a podcast. Well, thank you so much. Everyone listening is loving that photo right now.
如果那挂在我家里，我会吓死的。超级诡异。或者我在的任何房间。我知道。我原以为能延续我在播客里展示视觉资料的传统。好吧，非常感谢。每个在听节目的观众现在都很喜欢那张照片。
Of a 3D velvet wolf. All right. We're going to break. We'll be right back. We're back. And before we start breaking down this incredibly awkward scene with Gabe, Angela, I need to say that I love your sweater that says love.
一张3D绒毛狼的照片。好了。我们要去休息一下。我们马上回来。我们回来了。在开始剖析盖布这个极其尴尬的场景之前，安吉拉，我得说我好喜欢你这件写着“爱”的毛衣。
Thank you. I love it. I have a gray sweater and some really pretty sort of pastel colors that says love. Do you also have a sweatshirt that says love or does your sweatshirt say peace? It says grateful. Oh, I like that too.
谢谢。我也很喜欢。我有一件灰色毛衣，上面有一些非常漂亮的粉彩色，写着“爱”。你是不是也有一件写着“爱”的运动衫，还是你的运动衫写着“和平”？上面写着感恩。哦，我也很喜欢那个。
Thanks. You're being very positive in your clothing in 2023. I'm noticing. I should tell you guys, this sweater that I have on, I bought probably six years ago at the Gap. And when I put it on this morning, I said to Josh, I just wear the same old sweater, so over and over. Well, I want some new sweaters.
谢谢。我注意到你在2023年的穿着非常积极向上。我得跟你们说，我身上这件毛衣，我大概六年前在Gap买的。今天早上我穿上它的时候，我对乔希说，我就是一直重复穿同一件旧毛衣。好吧，我想买一些新毛衣。
I love this sweater. Thank you. If you get a new sweater, please don't get rid of this sweater. Maybe my thing as I age is I just wear clothing with motivational words. I would love that as a character. Love, grateful, peace. You might have to have things specially made, I know.
我很喜欢这件毛衣。谢谢。如果你买了新毛衣，请不要把这件毛衣扔掉。也许我随着年龄增长的习惯就是只穿印有激励词汇的衣服。我作为角色会很喜欢这个设定。爱，感恩，和平。我知道，你可能得定做一些东西。
All right, so let's talk about this scene with Gabe. Aaron's on the phone and he just walks up and just hangs up her phone call. And she says they're just going to call back. Yeah. But he goes on a whole rant. He says he's in love with her. And he says, you know, I don't believe in much.
好吧，我们来谈谈和盖布的这场戏。艾琳正在打电话，他直接走过去挂了她的电话。然后她说他们会回电话的。是的。但他开始了一番长篇大论。他说他爱她。他说，你知道，我不相信很多东西。
I don't believe in horoscopes. Or Christmas. Or God. And her reaction to that, she's not happy. Oh, Angela's over the partition as well. Angela's like, excuse me? Oh, Ben R. from Boston noted your scoff in disgust, as he put it.
我不相信星座。或者圣诞节。或者上帝。而她对此的反应，她很不高兴。哦，安吉拉也探出隔板了。安吉拉就像是，不好意思？哦，来自波士顿的本·R.注意到了你那充满嫌弃的冷笑，正如他所说。
And so Gabe starts backpedaling. It's very funny. He's like, I just mean like he's not an old man with a beard. And Aaron is still like, oh. She's like, maybe he's an old man with a beard. Ben, for my head to be that high above the partition, I was standing on an apple box. You were.
于是盖布开始打圆场。非常搞笑。他说，我只是指他不是个留胡子的老头。而艾琳依然是一副，哦。她就像是，也许他是个留胡子的老头。本，为了让我的头高出隔板那么多，我当时站在一个苹果箱上。你确实站了。
Yeah. So that we could see you scoff and disgust. Because otherwise you just would have seen the top of my forehead. Did you notice that at eight minutes, Jordan is sitting at Dwight's desk. She has taken over his desk. Yes, I did notice.
是的。这样我们才能看到你嫌弃的冷笑。因为否则你只能看到我额头的顶部。你有没有注意到在八分钟的时候，乔丹坐在德怀特的桌子旁。她接管了他的办公桌。是的，我注意到了。
Well, now we're back in Dwight's office. Dwight has called Jim in because he wants to talk to him because Joe is coming. And he doesn't want Jim to cause any problems. That's right. No pranking with Joe here. Jim really takes in the room. He's like, wow, this is quite the decor.
好吧，现在我们回到了德怀特的办公室。德怀特把吉姆叫了过来，因为他想跟他谈谈，因为乔要来了。他不想吉姆惹出任何麻烦。没错。有乔在，可不能恶作剧。吉姆真的在打量这个房间。他说，哇，这装潢真别致。
And Dwight starts to point things out to him. Yes, this is when we learned that the gun on his desk is a Beaumont Adams. Yeah, he thought maybe Joe might like it, might give them something to talk about. Yeah, I guess she collects guns. Yeah. OK.
然后德怀特开始向他指出一些东西。是的，这就是我们得知他桌上的枪是博蒙特·亚当斯的原因。是的，他觉得乔可能会喜欢，可能会给他们一些共同语言。对，我猜她收集枪支。对。好的。
Also, this is when he mentions his rescue piranha, as well as his desk, which is, he says, a replica of Uday Hussain's desk. He read an article in Newsweek. Here's something I remember about that desk, Angela. I remember that it was made out of wood. It was very light. And they painted it to look like marble.
还有，这时他提到了他的宠物食人鱼，以及他的办公桌，他说那是乌代·侯赛因办公桌的复制品。他在《新闻周刊》上读到过一篇文章。安吉拉，关于那张桌子，我记得有一件事。我记得它是木头做的。非常轻。然后他们把它涂成了大理石的模样。
And I would just go in and stare at it because I was so impressed with this painting job. I thought it was amazing. You know what I thought about when I rewatched this episode was if that desk was truly marble and that big, they would not have been able to get it through the door and in the room. You would have to build a room around that desk.
我就会走进去盯着它看，因为我对这个油漆活印象太深了。我觉得它太棒了。你知道我重看这一集时在想什么吗，如果那张桌子真的是大理石做的而且那么大，他们根本无法把它搬进门并放进房间里。你得围着那张桌子建一个房间。
Also, in the commentary, Justin and Mindy shared that it was Mindy's idea to have this desk. Oh, I love it. Well, this was a whole thing, this desk, how they built it. I asked Randy because I told him my memory of loving it. And he said, the writers had originally pitched that the desk was like a solid black onyx. But Michael Gallenberg, our production designer,
另外，在评论音轨中，贾斯汀和曼迪分享说，拥有这张桌子是曼迪的主意。哦，我太喜欢了。好吧，这张桌子，他们是怎么建造的，这可是个大工程。我问了兰迪，因为我告诉他我记忆中对它的喜爱。他说，编剧们最初提议桌子应该像是一块纯黑缟玛瑙。但我们的制作设计师迈克尔·加伦伯格，
said that that would just suck out all the light in the room. It wouldn't look good on camera. And he thought it would be more visually interesting if we made it out of marble. So Tim James built it out of lumber. And then we hired this guy, Ron Henson, who is an amazing painter to paint it to look like marble. Well, you would never know that that was like a fakie desk.
说那会吸光房间里的所有光线。在镜头前不好看。他认为如果我们用大理石制作，视觉上会更有趣。于是蒂姆·詹姆斯用木材建造了它。然后我们雇了这个名叫罗恩·汉森的家伙，他是一个了不起的画家，把它画成大理石的样子。好吧，你绝对看不出那是个假桌子。
It looked so good. Justin said there was a reason why they over-decorated Dwight's office. And it was because they wanted to quote unquote hide the gun. He said that audiences are really smart. That audiences know if you introduce a gun into a storyline, that gun is going to go off. I guess it's called Chekhov's gun.
看起来太逼真了。贾斯汀在评论音轨里说，他们把德怀特的办公室过度装修是有原因的。那就是他们想“隐蔽”那把枪。他说观众真的很聪明。观众知道如果你在剧情中引入一把枪，那把枪就会开火。我想这就叫契诃夫之枪。
It's like a writer's theory. Oh, yeah. OK, so he thought that if he did everything he could to make the gun feel just like a minor prop among other ridiculous props, maybe, just maybe, the fact that Dwight fires the gun later would be a surprise. Well, I think he did a good job because he put it in a glass box. I didn't think it was going to get used.
这就像是一个编剧理论。哦，对。好吧，所以他觉得如果他尽其所能让这把枪感觉只是一堆荒谬道具中的一个普通小道具，也许，只是也许，德怀特后来开枪就会是一个惊喜。嗯，我觉得他做得很好，因为他把它放在一个玻璃盒子里。我以为它不会被用到。
I thought it was just another one of Dwight's swords and daggers and armor. Yeah. Justin said on the commentary, Jenna, that they broke down this episode so many times. It was a bit of a puzzle trying to figure out how to make Dwight the manager and what that would look like. But then also, where would it go?
我以为那只是德怀特的又一把剑、匕首和盔甲。是的。贾斯汀在评论音轨里说，珍娜，他们把这一集拆解了无数次。要想弄清楚如何让德怀特当经理以及那会是什么样子，简直就像是个拼图。但接着还要想，这剧情该往哪里走？
And it was the writer, Steve Healy's idea, that Dwight would become manager and screw it up all in one week. That's fun. So you had to have a big thing that would sabotage him being manager because he was probably going to be pretty good at it. Right.
然后是编剧史蒂夫·希利的创意，让德怀特当上经理并在短短一周内把一切搞砸。太有趣了。所以你得有一个大事件来破坏他当经理，因为他可能本来会干得挺不错的。对的。
Well, in the next scene, Dwight's going to open up a package. And inside is a gun holster. From his Uncle Honk. Yes. And he's so excited. He's so touched. Yeah.
好吧，在下一场戏中，德怀特要打开一个包裹。里面是一个枪套。来自他的洪克叔叔。是的。他太激动了。他太感动了。是的。
Well, Dwight immediately takes his gun holster, he puts his gun in it, and he starts parading around the office. Yeah. Everyone's like, Dwight, what are you doing? You can't just walk around with a gun in the office. And he's like, but my Uncle Honk made this for me. This is so special.
好吧，德怀特立刻拿过枪套，把枪放进去，开始在办公室里游行炫耀。是的。每个人都说，德怀特，你在干什么？你不能拿着枪在办公室里走来走去。而他说，但是我的洪克叔叔给我做的这个。这太特别了。
Yeah, he's like, you can't just walk around without a gun in it. You have to put the gun in it. And everyone's like pitching ideas. Well, why don't you put your phone in it? Why don't you put a banana in it? I would have loved to see him walking around with a banana in that holster.
对，他说，你不能不放枪就走来走去。你必须把枪放进去。然后大家都在出主意。好吧，你为什么不把手机放进去？你为什么不放根香蕉进去？我好想看他带着香蕉在那个枪套里走来走去。
I thought it was a good suggestion, actually, I have to say. Pam is going to threaten to call Joe. And that's when Dwight is like, fine. And he does a little twirly thing with the gun. He's going to put it back in the holster, but instead it fires right into the ground right next to Andy's ear.
我得说，其实我觉得这是个好建议。潘姆要威胁说要打电话给乔。然后德怀特就说，好吧。他用枪转了个圈。他本来要把枪放回枪套里，结果枪却走火了，子弹直接打在了安迪耳朵旁边的地板上。
And Andy grabs his ear. On the commentary, they were like, this was a really strong cutaway because that was the act break. That's a pretty strong act break. Well, we got a lot of questions about this moment. First of all, Dash P from Connecticut said, did rain fire a blank, or was the flash and gunshot
安迪抓住了他的耳朵.在评论音轨里，他们说，这是一个非常强烈的转场，因为那是幕间休息。这算是一个相当强烈的幕间休息。好吧，我们收到了很多关于这个时刻的问题。首先，来自康涅狄格州的达什·P说，雷恩开枪用的是空包弹，还是枪口闪光和枪声是后期添加的？
sound added in post? No, that was not added in post. Rain fired a blank. That was a real working gun. Randy explained that a blank is a cartridge that contains no projectile. It just has gunpowder in it. We used what was called a quarter round, which
不，那不是后期添加的。雷恩开的是空包弹。那是一支真正能运作的枪。兰迪解释说，空包弹是一种不含弹头的弹药。里面只有火药。我们使用的是一种叫做四分之一装药的弹药，
holds about a fourth of the amount of gunpowder, I guess. But still, firing a blank can be really dangerous. And even a quarter round makes a very loud noise. It produces that muzzle flash. So in order to do this, the crew held multiple rehearsals without any cast on set. We had a full safety meeting, I remember that. And they handed out those special shooter's earplugs
大概只含有四分之一左右的火药。但是，开空包弹仍然非常危险。即使是四分之一装药也会产生非常大的噪音。它会产生枪口闪光。因此，为了拍摄这个场景，剧组在没有演员在场的情况下进行了多次排练。我记得我们开过一次完整的安全会议。他们分发了那些特殊的射击耳塞，
for us all to wear. Just for the sound. Because it was a very loud noise. It's a very loud pop. And Randy said we did it in one take. Well, one of the things they talked about on the commentary was the idea that Dwight does something that's definitely going to get him removed from acting manager.
让我们所有人都戴上。仅仅是为了声音。因为那是很大的噪音。那是一个非常响亮的爆破声。兰迪说我们一次就拍过了。好吧，他们在评论音轨中谈到的事情之一，就是德怀特做了一件绝对会导致他被解除代理经理职务的事。
But also making sure the way they shot it, it was very clear that no one was injured. We also got a fan question from Zach T. in Illinois, who said, regarding Dwight's gun, after doing some research, it seems that the gun that Dwight used resembles a Remington 1875 American-made revolver. However, Dwight refers to it as a Beaumont Adams, which was a British service revolver from the mid-late 19th century.
但同时也要确保拍摄方式非常清晰，证明没有人受伤。我们还收到了来自伊利诺伊州的扎克·T.的粉丝提问，他说，关于德怀特的枪，经过一些研究，似乎德怀特使用的枪类似于雷明顿1875美式左轮手枪。然而，德怀特却称其为博蒙特·亚当斯，那是19世纪中后期的一款英国军用左轮手枪。
That actually looks very different than the gun that was used in this episode. What gun was used for the prop? And how did the writers decide on calling it a Beaumont Adams, despite the fact that it looks nothing like a Beaumont Adams? Well, Zach, good catch. That was not a Beaumont Adams. So we hired an armorer for this scene.
这实际上看起来和这一集里使用的枪非常不同。道具使用的是什么枪？编剧们又是怎么决定叫它博蒙特·亚当斯的，尽管它看起来一点也不像博蒙特·亚当斯？好吧，扎克，你观察得很仔细。那确实不是博蒙特·亚当斯。所以我们为这场戏雇了一位军械师。
And he informed us that there are no credible working replicas of a Beaumont Adams. It couldn't be found. He said, we could have one built, but it would take months. Oh, wow. So the producers decided to go with this Remington 1875. It was a modern-day build of a classic revolver. And because this was not some sort of antique gun,
他告诉我们，市面上没有可靠且能运作的博蒙特·亚当斯复制品。根本找不到。他说，我们可以让人定制一把，但这需要几个月的时间。哦，哇。所以制片人决定选用这款雷明顿1875。这是对经典左轮手枪的现代复刻版。由于这不是那种古董枪，
but a modern-made gun, it was considered safer to handle. It could really fire a blank. So we went with that. But the writers chose to keep the Beaumont Adams reference just because they thought it was funny, and that it sounded like something that Joe might recognize and appreciate.
而是一把现代制造的枪，操作起来更安全。它确实能发射空包弹。所以我们就用了它。但编剧们选择保留博蒙特·亚当斯的称呼，纯粹是因为他们觉得这很有趣，而且听起来像是乔可能会认出并欣赏的名字。
Justin said, internet gun aficionados have called them out on this cheat before. You know, Angela, I remember it was loud. Do you remember that? Yeah. I mean, we didn't have to pretend to jump. No, all of our reactions were very real. For sure.
贾斯汀说，网上的枪械爱好者以前就曾指出过他们这个穿帮点。你知道，安吉拉，我记得声音很大。你还记得吗？是的。我的意思是，我们根本不用假装被吓一跳。不，我们所有的反应都是极其真实的。肯定的。
At 11 minutes and 26 seconds, Oscar is going to examine the gunshot hole that is in the floor. Right? Yes. And he's going to say, look at that. Hardwood floor is underneath this carpet. All along. I would like to point out that while Oscar is examining
在11分26秒时，奥斯卡去检查地板上的那个弹孔。对吧？是的。然后他说，看那个。地毯下面竟然是硬木地板。一直都是。我想指出的是，当奥斯卡在检查地板的损坏情况时，你能看到约翰的桌子底下有一个取暖器。
the damage to the floors, you can see that John had a heater under his desk. What? Yeah. John? All this time, I thought it was just us, but John has a heater under his desk. I took a picture.
什么？对。约翰？一直以来，我还以为只有我们这样，结果约翰的桌子底下也有个取暖器。我拍了张照片。
I am like, I'm shocked right now. I was shocked as well. I know I should be like focusing on the episode and this big plot point just happened, but I couldn't get my eyes off a heater under John's desk. Wow. Check it out. And it's on.
我整个人就是，我现在惊呆了。我也惊呆了。我知道我应该专注于这一集以及这个刚刚发生的大剧情，但我的眼睛根本无法从约翰桌子底下的取暖器上移开。哇。你们看。而且它是开着的。
Yeah. The little red light is on. Well, Toby's going to come in to see what's going on. Kelly's going to say that Dwight went on a shooting spray. Background catch at 11 minutes 45 seconds. Did you guys catch that Dwight hands his gun to Creed? And I guess Creed is going to get rid of it? Yeah.
对。那个小红灯是亮的。好吧，托比要进来看看怎么回事。凯利要说德怀特开启了一场疯狂枪击。11分45秒的背景彩蛋。你们抓到了吗，德怀特把枪递给了克里德？我猜克里德是要把它处理掉？是的。
I mean, if anyone knows how to get rid of a gun in this office, it's probably Creed. Just such a great- Don't you think maybe this isn't the first gun he's gotten rid of? I'm just saying. I mean, he lives under the desk. He has a whole other life in Canada.
我的意思是，如果这办公室里有人知道怎么处理一把枪，那可能就是克里德。太棒了——你不觉得也许这已经不是他处理掉的第一把枪了吗？我只是随便说说。我的意思是，他就住在桌子底下。他在加拿大还有另一段人生。
We don't know. We don't know. Well, Oscar wants to look up some of Andy's symptoms on WebMD, which gets some great snark from Angela. This is one of my favorite Angela Martin lines of all of season seven. In the script, it was written like this, and we shot it exactly as it was written.
我们不知道。我们不知道。好吧，奥斯卡想在WebMD上查一下安迪的一些症状，这引来了安吉拉精彩的挖苦。这是我最喜欢的第七季安吉拉·马丁台词之一。剧本里是这样写的，我们也是完全按照剧本拍摄的。
Oscar says, I'll look on WebMD. What are your symptoms? Angela in parentheses, sarcastic. Oh, everybody, Oscar found a reason to look on WebMD. I love the assumed history of these two characters. I love knowing that he looks on WebMD so much that it has driven her crazy for years. I think it's lines like this that really made this feel
奥斯卡说，我去WebMD上查查。你有什么症状？括号里的安吉拉，讽刺地。哦，大家快看，奥斯卡又找到理由上WebMD了。我太喜欢这两个角色之间这种默认的历史了。我喜欢知道他经常上WebMD，以至于多年来把她逼疯了。我觉得正是这样的台词，才真正让这一集感觉
like a nostalgic old office episode. And also like the stuff at the copier. We just brought back, I feel like, some of that mundane office work kind of stuff and relationship stuff. Yeah. I want you to know that when Toby gets excited to go get his new safety binder, I really felt that.
像一集充满怀旧感的老办公室剧集。还有复印机旁边的那些戏。我觉得我们带回了一些那种平凡的办公室日常工作和人际关系之类的东西。是的。我想让你们知道，当托比兴奋地去拿他的新安全手册文件夹时，我真的很有共鸣。
I would be excited to use a new binder. You know, I have a lot of stuff in my house that is for various emergencies. And I'm not saying that I want a zombie apocalypse or that I want any kind of apocalypse or end of times, but if it happened, I would be so excited to grab my expired medications book bag. You know, I would just be like, I knew it.
我会很兴奋能使用一个新文件夹。你知道，我家里有很多东西都是为了各种紧急情况准备的。我不是说我想要僵尸末日，或者我想要什么末日或世界末日，但如果真的发生了，我会超级兴奋地抓起我的过期药物书包。你知道，我就会觉得，我早就知道了。
I really can't wait for you to meet the character of Bill in The Last of Us. I need you to meet Bill. Okay. I'm not gonna say anything else. All right. But speaking of Toby and how excited he was, you know, to have his emergency binder.
我真的迫不及待想让你在《最后生还者》里认识比尔这个角色。我需要你认识比尔。好吧。我什么都不说了。好。但说到托比以及他拿到紧急文件夹时有多兴奋，
Jenna, do you remember when we were filming this when Paul came out to say all that? He had to address the bullpen. Yes. And he mumbled so badly, we couldn't understand him. We even improvised, what are you saying, Toby? Speak up. We started laughing so hard.
珍娜，你还记得我们拍摄这一幕时保尔出来说所有台词的情景吗？他必须对办公室员工发表讲话。是的。他嘟囔得太厉害了，我们根本听不懂他在说什么。我们甚至即兴发挥了，你在说什么，托比？大声点。我们开始笑得喘不过气来。
And I don't know if it was Paul or Paul being Toby, but he really struggled getting that line out. I feel like that made it onto the bloopers. It definitely made it on, you know, they would do blooper reels and stuff for our end of season cast parties that we would have. And I remember it was definitely on there. It's definitely on there, yeah.
我不知道那是保尔还是保尔在演托比，但他真的很难把那句台词顺畅地说出来。我觉得那段被剪进NG花絮里了。绝对剪进去了，你知道的，我们每年季终剧组聚会时都会制作NG花絮之类的视频。我记得那绝对在里面。绝对在里面，是的。
Dwight is now gonna do his best Michael, which is where he calls a conference room meeting and creates a character to cover up his screw up. Gun safety Dwight. Yeah. I'm the rootness to, and he just can't do it. He reels immediately. He does.
德怀特现在要发挥他最好的迈克尔水平，也就是他召开了一场会议，并创造了一个角色来掩盖他的搞砸。枪支安全德怀特。对。我是……，他根本说不下去。他立刻破功了。他确实破功了。
He does give a pretty great speech though. He says, managing you for this last week has been the greatest honor of my life. And if you ruin this, I will burn this office to the ground. And I mean that figuratively, not literally, because you guys are so, so important to me. I love you guys, but don't cross me, but you're the best. Rain said that that final monologue at the end
不过他确实发表了一段相当精彩的演讲。他说，过去这一周管理你们是我一生中最大的荣誉。如果你们毁了这一切，我会把这个办公室烧成平地。我说的是比喻意义，不是字面意义，因为你们对我来说实在太重要了、太重要了。我爱你们，但不要惹我，不过你们是最棒的。雷恩说最后的那段独白
was really hard for him to get through. And it was really in that moment that he realized everything Steve went through, leading those conference room meetings. Yeah. I thought he did such a great job though, because he had to turn on a dime back and forth, back and forth.
对他来说真的很难演过去。也就是在那一刻，他真正体会到了史蒂夫领导那些会议时所经历的一切。是的。不过我觉得他做得太棒了，因为他必须像变魔术一样瞬间切换，来回切换。
Many times. Yeah. Andy and Daryl are gonna come back from the hospital. Andy's got like a little bandage on his ear, and he shares with everyone that he ruptured his eardrum. That's right. And he has temporary deafness in that ear. I have a deep dive on burst eardrums.
好多次。是的。安迪和达里尔要从医院回来了。安迪的耳朵上贴着一小块纱布，他跟所有人分享说他的耳膜破裂了。没错。而且他那只耳朵暂时性失聪了。我对耳膜破裂做了一番深入研究。
Wait, before you go on the deep dive, I have to tell you one thing. Justin said on the commentary, he said, they were so worried that people were gonna get grossed out by this injury, that they were trying to find different ways toward it. And at one point in the script, they had Andy saying, my ear don't work so good.
等等，在你开始深入研究之前，我得告诉你一件事。贾斯汀在评论音轨中说，他们当时非常担心人们会被这个伤情恶心到，所以他们试图寻找不同的表达方式。在剧本的某个地方，他们让安迪说，我的耳朵不太好使了。
Oh, my ear no do work. They had all these different phrases, but ultimately they had to say, that he's gonna have this injured eardrum. And I just feel like I have to bring that up, because I don't know what to expect from this deep dive. They were worried, a group of writers who had researched it that people were gonna get grossed out.
哦，我的耳朵不好使。他们有各种不同的台词，但最终他们不得不说，他将会有这个受伤的耳膜。我感觉我必须把这个提出来，因为我不知道接下来这个深入研究会带来什么。他们当时很担心，一帮做过研究的编剧担心观众会被恶心到。
I'm not gonna explain everything that happens when you have a burst eardrum. Thank you. Except to say that the symptoms that Andy complains about are symptoms of a burst eardrum. The ringing in the ear, the hearing loss, the pain, all of those things. What I got curious about was,
我不会解释耳膜破裂时发生的所有事情。谢谢。只想说安迪抱怨的症状确实是耳膜破裂的症状。耳鸣、听力丧失、疼痛，所有这些。让我好奇的是，
can a loud noise burst your eardrum? Is that true? Is that possible that this gunshot sound burst his eardrum? Sure, I'm gonna say sure. The answer is yes. You can get a perforated eardrum, which is a burst eardrum,
巨大的噪音真的能震破耳膜吗？这是真的吗？这枪声真的有可能震破他的耳膜吗？当然，我说是就是。答案是肯定的。你的耳膜会穿孔，也就是耳膜破裂，
from a loud sound, a foreign object in your ear, like a Q-tip, head trauma, an ear infection, or rapid pressure changes. Hmm. Like either, or going down into the ocean. You know, if you dive down too fast. Submarined. Yeah.
原因可能是巨大的声音、耳朵里的异物（比如棉签）、头部创伤、耳部感染，或者气压急剧变化。嗯。比如潜水，或者潜入海洋深处。你知道，如果你下潜得太快。潜水艇。是的。
Or a submarine, sure. Just gonna yell. Different modes of transportation. Sure. To either up high or down low. Yeah, exactly. But getting back to this idea of your eardrum rupturing from a loud noise, I wanted to know, like how loud
或者潜水艇，当然。就大喊大叫。不同的交通方式。当然。要么去高处，要么去低处。对，没错。但回到噪音导致耳膜破裂这个概念上来，我想知道，声音究竟要有多大
does the noise have to be? And according to Better Hearing of Austin, it would have to be 165 decibels or more. And that would be consistent with a gunshot at close range. Fireworks, or extremely loud music. So I mean, I had to keep going here. OK. How loud of the music.
声音必须有多大？根据奥斯汀“更好听力”组织的说法，它必须达到165分贝或更高。这与近距离枪击的声音相符。烟花，或者极其高声的音乐。所以我的意思是，我得继续说下去了。好吧。音乐得有多大声。
OK. You know, my son plays in a rock band. Yeah. He wears headphones, but I'm like, what? You know. So the average decibel level of a rock concert is 100 decibels, so well below. Yeah.
好吧。你知道，我儿子在一个摇滚乐队里演奏。是的。他戴着耳机，但我总是想，什么？你知道。所以摇滚音乐会的平均分贝水平是100分贝，远低于那个标准。是的。
However, there have been several rock concerts that have registered levels of up to 130 decibels. Do you know who they were? These are the loudest rock bands on record. There's four of them. Metallica? No. Oh.
然而，有几场摇滚音乐会的音量记录高达130分贝。你知道它们是谁吗？这些是有记录以来声音最大的摇滚乐队。有四个。金属乐队？不是。哦。
Good guess. Here they are. Led Zeppelin. Oh. ACDC. I was going to say ACDC. Yep. Motorhead.
猜得不错。它们在这里。齐柏林飞船。哦。AC/DC。我本来想说AC/DC的。是的。摩托头。
Back in black. Yeah. And Ted Nugent. They're all very loud. I was about to say ACDC. I really was. I was going to say ACDC or Metallica. So I kind of got one on the list.
黑色安息日。对。还有特德·纽根特。它们声音都非常大。我刚才正要说AC/DC。我真的是。我本打算说AC/DC或金属乐队。所以我算是在名单上猜中了一个。
Sporting events have also recorded very high decibel levels, and the loudest one on record belongs to a certain football team. It was a home game. It came in at 142.2 decibels. OK, this would have to be a team that plays in some kind of a dome, right, to contain the sound. I don't know anything about where they play.
体育赛事也记录了非常高的分贝水平，有记录以来声音最大的纪录属于某个橄榄球队。那是一场主场比赛。分贝高达142.2。好吧，这肯定是一支在某种穹顶体育场里比赛的球队，对吧，为了把声音聚拢起来。我对他们在哪儿比赛一无所知。
I bet it's a team with a dome. That's what I'm going to say. They're very topical right now. The Philadelphia Eagles? Nope. The Kansas City Chiefs. I knew it would be one of them. Loudest one.
我敢打赌这是一支拥有穹顶体育场的球队。我猜是这样。他们现在可是热门话题。费城老鹰队？不是。堪萨斯城酋长队。我就知道是他们其中之一。声音最大的一支。
They took the record away from the Seahawks. I want you to know that just for some perspective, 142.2 decibels is louder than if you were standing under a jet airplane flying 100 feet above your head. Wow. That's how loud that was in the stadium. I'm looking up their stadium.
他们从海鹰队手里夺走了这个纪录。我想让你们知道，为了有个直观的概念，142.2分贝比你站在一架在头顶100英尺处飞过的喷气式飞机下方还要吵。哇。体育场里的声音就是这么大。我在查他们的体育场。
You want to know if it's a dome? Yeah. Well, those Chiefs fans are loud. It's not a dome. It's not. That's how loud they are. Open air. Wow.
你想知道它是不是穹顶体育场吗？对。好吧，那些酋长队的球迷声音是真大。它不是穹顶。不是的。他们就是这么大声。露天的。哇。
Yep. I did say hi to Patrick Mahomes once. You did? I did. I just said, hi, Patrick. He said, what's up? What are the circumstances of you meeting him? I was on the field at a Broncos game,
是的。我确实跟帕特里克·马霍姆斯打过招呼。真的吗？是的。我只是说，嗨，帕特里克。他说，最近怎么样？你和他是怎么偶遇的？我当时在野马队比赛的球场上，
and he was warming up, and I walked past him, and I was like, oh, that's Patrick Mahomes. So I said, hi, Patrick. He said, what's up? Oh, what a pleasant exchange. I think I slightly embarrassed my kids, because I think I just was so casual. Hi, Patrick.
他正在热身，我从他旁边走过，然后我想，哦，那是帕特里克·马霍姆斯。所以我说，嗨，帕特里克。他说，最近怎么样？哦，多么愉快的交流。我想我可能稍微让我孩子们有点尴尬，因为我觉得我当时太随性了。嗨，帕特里克。
Like I was his neighbor. But he was very nice. He was nice. You know who I just ran into on a hike who was like a total blowhard? Oh, you're going to tell this story? I ran into a very famous musician who was walking his two dogs on the same hike
就像我是他邻居一样。但他非常友好。他人很好。你知道我刚才在远足时偶遇了谁吗，那人简直是个自大狂？哦，你要讲这个故事吗？我遇到了一位非常著名的音乐家，他在我和同一条徒步路线上遛他的两只狗。
that I was walking on. And he mansplained me about dogs. And then I said something to Lee about it, and Lee said, oh, yeah, he's a famous mansplainer. Who is the famous musician mansplainer? I don't know. I'll tell you after. Give me one hint.
然后他对我进行了一番关于养狗的说教。接着我把这事跟李说了一下，李说，哦，对，他是个著名的说教狂。这位著名的音乐家说教狂是谁？我不知道。我回头告诉你。给我一个提示。
I don't know how to give you a hint. Breather, heavy breather. No, he's very tall. That was just you sign. How about that? He's very tall. Oh, everybody's tall to me. Well, guys, we've got another episode of Office Ladies
我不知道怎么给你提示。呼吸急促的人，重度呼吸者。不，他很高。那只是你的标志。这样行吗？他很高。哦，对我来说所有人都很高。好吧，伙计们，我们还有另一集《办公室女士》
Burn It to the Ground. He clearly pissed you off on this hike. Because I didn't say anything to this person. He just started talking to you. He just started in. I'm just tall. And I mansplain. I'm just going to mansplain to you about dogs.
把它烧成平地。他在这次徒步中显然把你惹火了。因为我根本没跟这个人说话。他自己开始跟你搭话的。他自己就聊上了。我只是长得高。而且我喜欢说教。我就是要向你灌输关于狗的知识。
I didn't ask for advice. I didn't even say what kind of dog you have. I gave no indication that I even wanted to be spoken to. I'm sure you gave off the body language. I know that you have sometimes, which is don't talk to me. That I have sometimes. That's my default. I almost never want to be talked to.
我没有征求建议。我甚至都没说你养的是什么品种的狗。我没有任何迹象表明我甚至想跟人说话。你肯定散发出了那种肢体语言。我知道你有时会有那种，就是别跟我说话的表情。我有时确实会那样。那是我的默认状态。我几乎从不想跟人说话。
I am an introvert. I was trying to be nice. I just want to walk my dog on a hike. And be left alone. Exactly. Be alone, tall people. What's so hard about that? My dog had to stop and get a drink of water.
我是个内向的人。我本来只是想在远足时遛遛狗。然后被留独自一人。没错。高个子们，离我远点。这有什么难的？我的狗不得不停下来喝口水。
That was not an invitation to talk to me. Mansplain. It wasn't. Back to the episode, people are catching on now that Dwight doesn't want Joe to know about this. And they start making demands of him. Yes. Kelly asked for a day off to audition for American Idol.
那可不是跟我搭话的邀请。说教。根本不是。回到剧集本身，大家现在开始察觉到德怀特不想让乔知道这件事。他们开始向他提出要求。是的。凯利要求放一天假去参加《美国偶像》的试镜。
Phyllis wants an extra vacation day. Angela wants pet day back. No dogs. Kevin wants everything back in the vending machine. Except the fruit. Pam wants Dwight to get rid of all of his weapons, including the killer fish. Jim wants Dwight to work in the phrase Shagadelic Baby
菲利斯想要一个额外的假期。安吉拉想要宠物日回归。不要狗。凯文想要自动售货机里的所有东西都恢复原样。除了水果。潘姆要求德怀特除掉他所有的武器，包括那条杀人鱼。吉姆要求德怀特在与乔的对话中加入“Shagadelic Baby”这句口号，并且在吉姆每次咳嗽时都要做爵士手势。
into conversation with Joe and do jazz hands any time Jim coughs. But there was more. There were more demands that we didn't see? Yes, that we filmed because they were in the shooting draft. First of all, Dwight is going to offer to pay for Andy's medical bills. OK. Fair.
但还不止这些。还有我们没看到的其他要求？是的，我们拍了，因为它们在拍摄剧本里。首先，德怀特要主动提出支付安迪的医疗费用。好吧。公平。
Fair. Yeah. And then Andy says, but you know what? I also can't go to my swimming class at the Y. And I already paid for those. So Dwight's going to have to pay for his swimming process. I'm going to reimburse. OK.
公平。是的。然后安迪说，但你知道吗？我也不能去Y（基督教青年会）的游泳课了。而且我已经付过钱了。所以德怀特得支付他的游泳费用。我要报销。好的。
Daryl wants Dwight to honor the night school that D'Angelo had promised him. Also, fair. Aaron wants a new nameplate that doesn't say receptionist. Oh. I know. Stanley has the best one of the bunch. Ready for this?
达里尔希望德怀特兑现安吉洛曾经答应过他的夜校。同样，公平。艾琳想要一个新的名牌，上面不要写着前台接待。哦。我知道。斯坦利提出了所有人中最棒的一个要求。准备好听这个了吗？
He says, I want to start telecommuting from home because I am concerned for my safety in this office. Dwight agrees. Oh my gosh. And lastly, Creed wants Dwight's eyes. Not now. Once he is dead, he lets him know that. OK.
他说，我想开始在家远程办公，因为我担心我在这个办公室里的安全。德怀特同意了。哦天哪。最后，克里德想要德怀特的眼睛。不是现在。等他死了以后，他让他知道了这一点。好吧。
There you go. Those are everyone's demands. Well, in the next scene, Dwight's going to be exiting the men's bathroom. He's holding an empty fish tank. It's very clear that he has, I guess, flushed his piranha down the toilet. Kevin enters.
就这样。这就是每个人的要求。好吧，在下一场戏中，德怀特将从男洗手间出来。他手里拿着一个空鱼缸。很明显，他把他的食人鱼冲进马桶里了。凯文进来了。
Fan question from Madison B. and Melbourne, Australia. The short scene in which Dwight dumps his piranha into the toilet, leading to Kevin discovering them, has to be one of my favorite moments in the whole show. It causes me to cry from laughter every time I rewatch it. Kevin moves so fast out of there and is so shocked. Madison, I loved Brian Bomber's performance in this short moment.
来自澳大利亚墨尔本的麦迪逊·B.的粉丝提问。德怀特把食人鱼倒进马桶里，导致凯文发现它们的那个短暂场景，绝对是我整部剧中最喜欢的时刻之一。每次重看它，我都会笑得流泪。凯文逃得那么快，而且震惊无比。麦迪逊，我很喜欢布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳在这个短暂时刻的表演。
It is perfection. It's so believable. Like, I fully believe that Kevin just completely lost it because he was about to sit on a fish. I am assuming everyone out there knows how standards and practices felt about Kevin's F-bomb. We got the usual bleepful word, blur lip flap, or stage off camera.
简直是完美。太可信了。就像，我完全相信凯文当时彻底吓坏了，因为他差点坐在一条鱼上。我猜外面的所有人都知道“标准与实践”部门对凯文爆粗口的看法。我们听到了惯常的消音词、模糊的唇形或画外音。
Stage off camera is always my favorite now. They always throw that in there. Because if we're just going to, it makes no sense. My favorite is when they say, as previously stated, yes. You know, I did do another deep dive here. And I wasn't going to bring it up. I didn't even write it down. But wait, un-possibly what?
画外音现在绝对是我的最爱。他们总是会加上那个。因为如果我们直接去……这就毫无意义。我最喜欢的是他们说，如前所述，是的。你知道，我在这里又做了一次深入研究。我本来不打算提的。我甚至都没把它写下来。等等，怎么可能什么？
Fish in toilets? Did you deep? Come on, I did. I did it in there. I was like, wait, wait, why could you deep dive right here? What? I deep dived. What really happens when you flush a fish down the toilet?
把鱼冲进马桶？你真的去研究了？拜托，我真的研究了。我当时就在想，等等，为什么你现在能扯出个深度研究？什么？我做了一个深度研究。把鱼冲进马桶里到底会发生什么？
What happens? Most of them die. Oh. But I mean, aren't they dead usually? Yes. But after the movie, Finding Nemo came out, I guess there were some kids. There was a trend that happened where kids
会发生什么？大多数都会死。哦。但我的意思是，它们通常不就已经死了吗？是的。但自从电影《海底总动员》上映后，我猜有一些孩子。出现了一种潮流，孩子们
wanted to set their fish free. Oh, no. But not all toilets lead to the ocean. So most of them die. But this trend of kids freeing their fish down the toilet, I guess it caused a little bit of a problem. Because some of the fish did live. And they did make it all the way to these other reservoirs.
想放生他们的鱼。哦，不。但并不是所有的马桶都通向海洋。所以大多数都死了。但这种孩子们把鱼从马桶里放生的潮流，我猜引起了一点小麻烦。因为有些鱼确实活下来了。它们甚至一路游到了其他水库里。
And there's a picture of a goldfish that is giant. It's like a 15-inch goldfish because it was introduced into this ecosystem. And it started eating everything. And it completely took over. Because I guess goldfish don't belong in that ecosystem. And it was a whole thing that there are these wild domestic goldfish very similar to the flock
有一张金鱼的照片，大得惊人。那是一条大约15英寸的金鱼，因为它被引入了这个生态系统。它开始吞噬一切。并且彻底占领了那里。因为我猜金鱼根本不属于那个生态系统。这成了一件大事，就像那些野生的本地金鱼，非常类似于
of domestic parrots that fly around LA that have all found each other. Yeah. Or all the hippos in Colombia because of Pablo Escobar. What? Oh, yeah. There's a bunch of formerly domestic hippos that have formed. I don't think they were ever domestic.
在洛杉矶飞来飞去、已经互相找到彼此的成群家养鹦鹉。是的。或者哥伦比亚因为巴勃罗·埃斯科瓦尔而出现的河马。什么？哦，是的。有一群原本是家养的河马繁衍开来。我觉得它们从来都不是家养的。
He just like, I think he like built a zoo. He collected a bunch of animals. He had hippos. And then after he died, no one could maintain the zoo. And these hippos just went like, you know. So they were, they were, though, not domesticated. But they were what do you call that? He like made a zoo.
他只是，我记得他建了一个动物园。他收集了一堆动物。他有河马。然后在他死后，没有人能维护那个动物园了。这些河马就觉得，你知道的。所以它们其实不是被驯化的。但它们叫什么来着？他建了个动物园。
Right. He made a zoo. And then after he died, they couldn't maintain the zoo. And I guess hippos really get busy. Hippos are very dangerous. They're on the list of animals I said that kill humans, the top 10 animals. But they also get busy.
对。他建了个动物园。然后在他死后，他们无法维护动物园了。我猜河马真的很忙碌。河马非常危险。它们在我列出的杀害人类的动物前10名名单上。但它们也很忙。
They get busy. Boom, jicabum, boom, boom. And there's lots of them now. And they're like, I think there's like a whole documentary about it, about Pablo Escobar's hippos. Huh. Yeah.
它们忙得很。轰，吉卡邦，轰，轰。现在有好多好多河马。而且它们，我想甚至有一部关于它们的纪录片，关于巴勃罗·埃斯科瓦尔的河马。哈。是的。
OK. Well. Anyway, well, there's my deep dive. I don't even remember what websites I read. I didn't write it down because I wasn't going to bring it up and then I did. Well, I can't believe so many kids tried to flush their fish. I know.
好吧。总之，好吧，这就是我的深度研究。我甚至都不记得我读过哪些网站了。我没写下来，因为我本不打算提的，结果我还是提了。好吧，我真不敢相信有那么多孩子试图把鱼冲进马桶。我知道。
Oh my god. It was, I guess, the thing. Well, speaking of wild animals, how's that for a segue? Joe is going to arrive with her two dogs. Her Jack Russells. Speaking of wild animals, they are Cornelius and Bobo. Fan question from Ted N. in Virginia and Alania B. from Salt Lake City, Utah.
哦天哪。我猜这曾是一种风潮。好吧，说到野生动物，这个过渡怎么样？乔带着她的两只狗抵达了。她的杰克罗素梗。说到野生动物，它们叫科尼利厄斯和博博。来自弗吉尼亚州的特德·N.和犹他州盐湖城的阿兰娅·B.的粉丝提问。
What happened to her Great Danes? It has always bothered me that Joe shows up with different dogs. Well, she still has the Great Danes. I guess. I mean, I would think so. I feel like Joe is someone that has a ton of animals. In the DVD commentary, Justin said he thinks that Joe has different pairs of dogs
她的那些大丹犬怎么了？乔带着不同的狗出现，这件事一直困扰着我。好吧，她肯定还有那些大丹犬。我想。我的意思是，我猜是这样。我觉得乔是个拥有海量动物的人。在DVD评论音轨中，贾斯汀说他认为乔养了不同的几对狗，
to accessorize different outfits she wears. Oh. Joe has like a kennel somewhere in Florida. Well, I hope Joe doesn't die or there's suddenly going to be a bunch of dogs roaming around. You know what I'm saying? Joe is going to point out that Jim is the only man to have ever said no to her.
来搭配她穿的不同服装。哦。乔在佛罗里达某处有个狗舍吧。好吧，我希望乔千万别死，否则突然间会有一堆狗在到处乱跑。你知道我在说什么吗？乔指出吉姆是唯一一个对她说不的男人。
And then Jim Koff's and Dwight has to do jazz hands. This scene was bigger. In deleted scenes, Andy tries to cover for Dwight. And we also find out who is Joe's favorite in the office. Wait, let me guess. Oscar? Let's hear the clip. Where's my favorite?
然后吉姆咳嗽，德怀特不得不做爵士手势。这一段原本更长。在被删减的片段中，安迪试图为德怀特打掩护。我们还发现谁才是乔在办公室里的最爱。等等，让我猜猜。奥斯卡？我们听听这段音频。我的最爱在哪儿？
Where's Angela hiding? I'm not hiding. Girl, you are very small. It's fun to look at you so small. Oh my gosh. OK, now that you played that, I remember shooting that. Angela was her favorite. My gosh, that is funny.
安吉拉躲哪儿去了？我没躲。天哪，姑娘，你太娇小了。看你这么小真有意思。哦天哪。好吧，既然你放了这段，我想起拍摄时的情景了。安吉拉是她的最爱。天哪，太搞笑了。
Can we please talk about this incredibly elaborate and cringy under-the-jacket massage that Dwight gives to Kevin? 17 minutes, 52 seconds. I don't even know how Rain was able to do that with his body. How was he able to, like, suspend himself, like bracing his feet on the file cabinet, leaning into Brian? We talk on the commentary that when he first put all his weight
我们能聊聊德怀特给凯文做的这个极其复杂且让人脚趾抠地的夹克衫内按摩吗？17分52秒。我甚至不知道雷恩是怎么用他的身体做成那样的。他怎么能那样悬空，把脚撑在文件柜上，整个人压在布莱恩身上？我们在评论音轨里聊过，当他第一次把全部体重
on Brian's back like that, it made a popping noise. Yes. You know, Rain shared that it was Mindy's idea for Dwight to climb up the file cabinets like that. He said it was a huge workout for his core. I bet. I texted Brian about this because I was like, I can see Brian, like, pushing back so hard into Rain's body,
压在布莱恩背上时，发出了一声爆裂的响声。是的。你知道，雷恩分享说，让德怀特那样爬上文件柜是曼迪的主意。他说这对他的核心肌群来说是一场巨大的锻炼。我敢说。为此我给布莱恩发了信息，因为我想，我能看出布莱恩在拼命往后顶雷恩的身体，
like these two forces at work. Brian shared that he was sore for days after the scene. He said of all the prat falls, slipping on oil in the warehouse, spilling the chili, this was the stunt he felt the longest afterwards, this stunt. I believe it. Me too. If you watch the scene, his face is bright red.
就像这两种力量在较劲。布莱恩分享说，拍完这场戏后他酸痛了好几天。他说在所有的滑稽跌倒中，在仓库的油污上滑倒、打翻辣椒，这是他事后感觉最久的特技，就是这个特技。我相信。我也是。如果你看这场戏，他的脸红得像个苹果。
Also, look at me in Oscar. I was really like hearing Brian's body, like he was at the chiropractor, was like, pop, pop, pop. Well, Rain also said that at this time, I guess Brian had a shoulder injury. And one of the things was that they could do the stunt, but he could not get anywhere near that one shoulder. And that made it even more challenging
还有，看我在奥斯卡那一集里的表现。我真的听到布莱恩的身体，就像他在脊椎矫正诊所一样，发出卡哒、卡哒、卡哒的声音。呃，雷恩也说过，当时我猜布莱恩肩膀受了伤。其中一点是他们可以做特技动作，但他完全不能靠近那个肩膀。这让情况变得更有挑战性
because there was this whole area of Brian's back that he could not touch. The two of them are so brave whenever they do anything, they just go for it. And it was really hilarious and also super cringy. Well, Dwight has almost made it through this day with Joe being there and her not finding out. But then he just can't take it anymore.
因为布莱恩背上有很大一片区域是不能碰的。他们两个人在做任何事情时都非常勇敢，总是全力以赴。这真的超级搞笑，同时也超级尴尬。好吧，乔在店里而且一直没发现，德怀特这一天差点就蒙混过关了。但接着他实在是承受不住了。
He can't do it. He's tired of people holding this over his head, so he confesses. Yeah. And he says, you know, I hope that I can still keep this job. And Joe is like, of course you cannot keep this job. Kathy Bates is so funny in this. She just looks at him and says, no job.
他受不了了。他厌倦了别人把这事当作把柄压在他头上，所以他坦白了。是的。他说，你知道的，我希望我还能保住这份工作。而乔的反应是，你当然保不住这份工作。凯西·贝茨在这里面太搞笑了。她只是看着他说，没工作了。
No job. Also, she has a line that, again, I just want a whole line of mugs that are Joe phrases. Here's the line. Stop asking yourself easy questions so you can look like a genius. I was really good. Love it.
没工作了。另外，她有一句台词，我真的很想要一套印有乔的语录的马克杯。台词是这样的：别再问自己一些简单的问题来让自己看起来像个天才了。这段真的很棒。太喜欢了。
I know they wrote so well for her. After this scene in the shooting draft would have been a scene between Aaron and Gabe in the break room. It would sort of wrapped up their storyline. I'm going to call it cringiest in the break room. Ooh. He writes her a poem.
我知道他们为她写台词写得太棒了。拍摄剧本中，这一幕之后本该是埃隆和加比在休息室的一场戏。这本来可以算是给他们的故事线收尾。我姑且称之为休息室里最尴尬的一幕。哦。他给她写了一首诗。
Oh, no. I want you to hear it. No, God. You charm me with a smile, a wink, and make me laugh. Like Monster's Inc. We're going to eat some ratatouille. I sure hope it's not too chewy. I'm Nemo in The Great Blue Seas.
哦，不。我想让你听听。噢，天哪。你用微笑、眨眼吸引我，逗我笑。就像《怪兽电力公司》。我们要去吃些法国杂菜煲。我敢打赌它不会太有嚼劲。我是《海底总动员》里的尼莫
I'm Woody. Be my Jesse, please. Please go out with me again. Please. You know, bless his heart for referencing her favorite films finally, but Gabe, maybe. Maybe if you had done that earlier, yeah, things wouldn't have gone south.
我是伍迪。请做我的杰西吧。请再跟我约会一次。求你了。你知道，感谢老天，他终于致敬了她最喜欢的电影，但是加比，也许。也许如果你早点这么做的话，事情就不会变得一团糟了。
He binged all the Disney movies she loves. He also goes on to say, I'm sorry that I said you spend too much money on stickers. He really makes a big apology, but she's done. She's done. This episode ends with Jo in the conference room. She's meeting with Gabe, Jim, and Toby, and she explains, you are my search committee.
他把她喜欢的迪士尼电影都看完了。他接着还说，很抱歉我说你在贴纸上花太多钱了。他真的很诚恳地道了歉，但她受够了。她已经受够了。这一集的结尾是乔在会议室里。她正在和加比、吉姆以及托比开会，她解释说，你们就是我的搜寻委员会。
You are tasked with finding her a new manager. And until that time, the person with the most seniority will be the new acting manager. Who is that? Who is it? Who has the most seniority? The looks they give each other because they all know it's Creed.
你们的任务是为她找一个新经理。在此之前，资历最高的人将担任新的代理经理。那是谁？是谁？谁的资历最高？他们互相递过的眼神，因为他们都知道那是克里德。
So priceless. The episode will end with a tag. And it is Angela, Daryl, and Kevin back at the copier. This was not in the shooting draft. In fact, the tag in the shooting draft was Ryan and Andy helping Kelly with her American Idol audition. OK.
真是太无价了。这一集将以一个彩蛋结束。那就是安吉拉、达里尔和凯文回到复印机旁。这在拍摄剧本里是没有的。事实上，拍摄剧本里的彩蛋是瑞恩和安迪帮凯莉参加《美国偶像》试镜。好吧。
Justin shared in the DVD commentary that this whole tag with us by the copier was completely improvised. That's exactly how I remember it. It was so much flip and fun. They literally just put the cameras on us and let it roll. Wait, so you were just listing numbers, and then Kevin says, oh, sorry, I did a three instead of a two.
珍妮在DVD评论音轨中分享说，我们复印机旁的整个彩蛋完全是即兴发挥的。我记的就是这样。太有趣、太欢乐了。他们 literalmente（字面意思）把摄像机对着我们，然后任由它拍。等等，所以你只是在报数字，然后凯文说，哦，对不起，我把2按成3了。
I literally was just reading out numbers. I had just written a bunch of numbers on a piece of paper. OK. When Craig jumps in, that was improvised. When Oscar jumps in, improvised how I react to Oscar, improvised all of it, improvised, I want to play it. Please, I love it so much. Four, one, seven, one.
我字面意思就是在读数字。我刚刚在一张纸上写了一堆数字。好的。当克雷格插话时，那是即兴的。当奥斯卡插话时，我对奥斯卡的反应也是即兴的，全都是即兴的，我想玩一下。拜托，我太喜欢了。四，一，七，一。
Another one? Yes. Seven, two, six, nine. Shut up, Oscar. Eight. Nine first, put the nine. Nine, eight, five. Thank you.
还有一个？对。七，二，六，九。闭嘴，奥斯卡。八。先按九，把九按上。九，八，五。谢谢。
Three, zero, zero. Again, zero, four, six. Nice. Two, one. I hit three instead. God! What I love are the multiple zeros in a row, because I've had those where you're trying to explain,
三，零，零。再来，零，四，六。不错。二，一。我按成三了。天哪！我最喜欢的是连续好几个零，因为我也遇到过那种情况，你试图解释
maybe it's your credit card, maybe it's a pin number or something, and you have to make sure that the person knows. You mean another one. Yeah, I just loved too when Craig was like, no, no, hit nine again. And I'm like, and then eight. And then Oscar's like, you guys, the beeping, and I keep going, four, two, shut up Oscar, nine.
也许是你的信用卡，也许是密码之类的，你必须确保对方明白。你是说另一个。对，我也很喜欢当克雷格说，不，不，再按一次九。然后我说，然后是八。然后奥斯卡说，你们这些哔哔声，而我一直说，四，二，闭嘴奥斯卡，九。
We had such a good time. We could have done it all day. And I love that they left it in as the tag. Well, guys, that was Dwight K. Shrut, acting manager. Next week, we'll be back with search committee part one. We're getting to the end of season seven. Where is the time going? This is flying by, Jenna.
我们玩得太开心了。我们本来可以整天都这么拍。我很高兴他们把这作为彩蛋保留了下来。好了，各位，这就是德怀特·K·施鲁特，代理经理。下周我们将回归搜寻委员会第一部分。我们正接近第七季的尾声。时间都去哪儿了？时间过得太快了，珍娜。
I know. It's because we're having so much fun. It is. Thanks, you guys, so much for listening and rewatching with us. We'll see you next week. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher,
我知道。那是因为我们玩得太开心了。确实如此。非常感谢大家收听并和我们一起重温。我们下周见。到时候见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍
and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoke. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com for a free one month
和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的助理制作人是艾恩斯利·巴比科克。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。想要收听无广告版本的《Office Ladies》，请访问StitcherPremium.com，使用优惠码
trial of Stitcher Premium use code, Office. OK. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Office即可免费试用一个月Stitcher Premium。好了。这一集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任何句子即可发表评论。